[Music]
thank you
good morning everyone it is seven
o'clock welcome to join us on the
breakfast show on Sky News live this
morning and set my calls on why for a
special program exactly three weeks
since Nicola bully dropped her children
off at school took the dog for a walk
along the river wire and then simply
disappeared as her family call for the
public to focus on finding her we'll
retrace Nicola's last known movements as
they happened later in the program and
the mountain criticism of Lancashire
police after it revealed personal
information about Nicholas struggle with
alcohol and the menopause now the Home
Secretary has weighed in it's Friday the
17th of February
three weeks and still no answers Nicola
Bully's family call for an end to
speculation and rumors and plea for help
to find her
the Home Secretary demands an
explanation from Lancashire police after
it revealed personal details about
Nicholas struggle with alcohol and the
menopause
the force refers itself to the police
Watchdog over contact its officers had
with the mum of two before she
disappeared
we'll retrace Nicholas steps this
morning as they happened on Friday three
weeks ago
also coming up nurses escalate their
industrial action announcing a fresh
48-hour strike the Royal College of
Nursing warns no services will be exempt
Rishi sunat visits Northern Ireland amid
growing speculation a new deal on
post-brexit trade Arrangements is close
the first candidates expected to
formally enter the running to become
Scotland's new first Minister as the SMP
reveals how the race will unfold
and the Hollywood Superstar Bruce Willis
has been diagnosed with frontotemporal
dementia
[Music]
morning everyone a special program live
for you today from Saint Michael's on
wire in Lancashire it's now exactly
three weeks since Nicola Bolly was last
seen after dropping her children off at
school and taking the dog for a walk the
mum of two's family have issued a fresh
plea for the public to focus on finding
her and to end the speculation about her
private life after Lancashire police
reveal personal details about her
struggle with alcohol and the menopause
the forces coming underground criticism
about those disclosures with even the
Home Secretary swella bravaman now
demanding answers we'll be live here
throughout the morning looking at the
circumstances surrounding her
disappearance and later in the program
we'll follow the same walk the 45 year
old took on that Friday morning three
weeks ago NC's been covering the story
for us throughout he's with us again
this morning it's just starting to get
light this is the river wire behind us
what do we know well this is Nicola
Bully's last known uh sighting this is
where she was with her phone
her dog Willow the Dog lead all left
around this bench behind us and what is
a very cold a very deep River wire
with a fairly steep bank and muddy Bank
on its way down to the river and it was
this it's only about two feet deep
though there on the edge around two feet
deep you go further into the river and
some local fishermen have actually told
us it can get up to about 20 25 feet
deep in some parts and it is a tidal
River the absolute nature of the river
wire means that this river flows back
and forth constantly and it's like a
strong tide no not right now but it does
move and it can move quickly in a matter
of minutes in fact if the police's
Theory their main hypothesis that
they've come up with and revealed early
on in their investigation that Nicola
bully accidentally fell into the river
wire then what they've said to me in the
last few days it is highly likely that
the mum of two has ended up at Sea
around 9 10 miles away from this point
into Morgan Bay and into the Irish sea
are there any scuff marks whether find
any scuff marks was there any blood on a
stone where she might have banged her
head or okay it's been three weeks there
wasn't a cord and set up around the
bench when Nicola bullies first reported
uh Missing no there was police presence
here and significant police presence but
there wasn't a crime scene as you would
usually see Nicola bully was marked
initially as a missing person a missing
person of high risk why was she high
risk it was due to specific
vulnerabilities that her family namely
her partner Paul had flagged to the
police just clarify the police have been
to the house two weeks before yes so it
was on the 10th of January that police
attended Nicola Bully's family home they
said that they attended on reports for
concerns for welfare that was on the
10th the medical team went as well yep
there were police there there was a
medical professionals that police said
went alongside with them and that was 17
days before Nicola went missing what
else happened in that 17 days we are
unsure of but what we do know is that on
that morning Friday the 27th of January
Nicola carried out her normal routine
dropped her kids off at school and took
her dog Willow for a walk along the
route that she would normally take what
happened in the 10 minutes that I
unaccounted for is still a huge let's
have a look at that should we in more
detail bear with me if you would please
she disappeared Friday morning exactly
three weeks ago look at what we do know
as Lindsay was saying they're from the
police about her movements that morning
she went missing early on the 27th after
traveling from a home in Inskip to the
nearby Village of Saint Michael's on
wire she dropped her children off at
school in the village that's on garstang
road Nicola then set off on her usual
walk with her dog Willow 843 along the
river wire footpath a dog walker who was
familiar with Nicholas saw her walking
around the lower fields at approximately
8 50. we'll show you all of this in more
detail later on 8 53 she used her mobile
phone to send an email to her boss then
at 901 Nicola logged into a team's call
for work at approximately ten past nine
a witness somebody who also knows
Nicholas Aura on the upper field walking
her dog we're going to place all this
for you so you can have a clear idea of
what happened 9 20 her phone moved
towards the bench area which is just
behind us towards the lower field at
around half past nine the team's call
ended but Nicola stayed logged on onto
that call Nicholas mobile phone and the
dog Willow were found nearby on the
bench behind us and the foot bath next
to the river by another dog walker at
approximately
09 33.
um Grand correspondent Martin brunt is
here with us as well but we don't know
what happened to her
no I mean the police have given us their
main working Theory
they've got into all sorts of trouble
because they didn't make it absolutely
clear when they announced that that
there were other theories that they were
still considering
um and they are still looking the
searches
keep going as he's been talking to India
about the movement of the river means
that when they clear some of the river
or they don't find uh Nicola they have
to go back at some stage because the
water has moved there's always I mean
let's let's not beat around the bush
when they say she went into the water
they're now looking for her body and
because of the water movements
um bodies can move so they clear one bit
of the river but they go back because
they think that perhaps her body might
have reappeared at an area that they've
already searched they've talked about
land searches around the coastal area
12 miles or so from here they finished
those land searches but the sea search
continues and it's not a forgiving Coast
that as I know from you know being this
part of the world not the easiest
searching a River Estuary is is
complicated I mean it's difficult enough
in a in a fast-moving River the coastal
area will present all sorts of problems
but they've got expert help it's not
just the police and they're divers who
are looking they've got fire service and
rescue they've got Mountain Rescue
Services that have been helping
rnli all sorts of expert help
and they say that they're determined um
to keep going and we've seen actually
boats out on the water all the way down
to the mouth of the river working their
way up the river wire where it's
incredibly tidal we're down at the sea
it is incredibly choppy as well so you
know if that is what they're looking for
a body in the water Nicola's body it is
incredibly difficult to do so but you've
been in touch with the family uh
constantly they don't think she went in
the water no the family want absolutely
every possibility explored you know the
police were very quick to jump to their
main working hypothesis that Nicola fell
into the river wire immediately the
family went hold on we want to make sure
the police's mind is open and that the
public who are still searching for her
that their mind is open as well they
want to make sure that absolutely every
Avenue is explored but okay look for a
family three weeks they're missing a
daughter they're missing a sister a
partner a mum they have gone through
absolute hell over the last three weeks
it has been a roller coaster ride it's
been an absolute turmoil and all they
want is Nikki to come home yeah so much
to talk about about this case isn't it
we're going to try and unpick it a bit
more throughout the course of the
program for now guys thanks very much
indeed thanks a lot Nicholas family have
uh said this it's now been three weeks
since Nikki went missing we as a family
believe that the public Focus has become
distracted from finding Nikki and more
about speculation and rumors into her
and Paul's private life due to the
perimenopause Nikki suffered with
significant side effects such as brain
fog Restless sleep and was taking HRT to
help but this was giving her intense
headaches which caused Nikki to stop
taking the HRT thinking that may have
helped her but only ended up causing
this crisis the public Focus has to be
on her and uh not making up wild
theories about her personal life
joined this morning by y Council leader
Michael Vincent Mr Vincent thank you for
taking the time to join us this morning
thoughts
um it's obviously very sad that we're
three weeks on and Nicola hasn't been
found
our thoughts with the family it's been a
very difficult time for them more than
anybody and it's been quite difficult
for the people of St Michael's as well
obviously with all the uh intrusion
visitors and all the other horrific
things that have been going on around
the case so it's been it's been a very
difficult three weeks for many years
social media seems to have played quite
a role in this case definitely yes
um I mean you've spoken then about the
police being criticized
this investigation has been conducted so
so far in the public eye everybody seems
to have a theory on social media
everybody seems to want to know all of
the information we learned yesterday
obviously that the police share of
clearly more information with the family
but have been criticized because they
didn't then share more information with
the public than they otherwise normally
would so it's been quite unprecedented I
think in terms of the interest in it I
mean we're we're here at the scene of a
missing person three weeks on from the
day so I've never done anything like it
um there's been a lot of criticism for
the police yeah where are you with that
uh I think that there are lessons to be
learned but I think that they've done
their best and very difficult
circumstances would you be concerned
with that sort of information about one
of your loved ones being out in the
public Arena uh I wouldn't like it but
as we already know from the statement
they put out yesterday that was put out
there with the knowledge of Nicole's
family in because other people were
seeking to make that information public
and that wasn't the police's decision of
their Hammer was forced should they have
done it
um again with the benefit of hindsight
that should be looked into for future
cases but I I think they've I think they
have done their best in very difficult
circumstances but if it was important to
the case should we not have known about
it earlier
uh perhaps and that's that's something
that perhaps is fueled some of the
online speculation and some of the
interest in the in the story uh but
again I think with the police have done
what they could in difficulty my
surprise were you that they didn't
cordon off this area as a crime scene
potential crime scene
um
quite but it's quite difficult to Corden
up I suppose and been a public footpath
and being people coming and going into
time between a bit of tape around it
perhaps yes uh again that's something
for them to look into to learn some
lessons from that how is this community
going to start to rebuild from from
what's Happening well the community has
stayed very strong it's a very small
place less than a thousand people yeah
indeed and they they've rallied around
they've they've been incredibly strong
for the family for the children of the
village and they've carried on looking
for Nicola in the right way they've
carried on trying to raise awareness
stood on the highway and sort of held
the pictures of her to try and raise
raise the memories of people who perhaps
have driven past on that day so
um the community has stayed strong
um obviously finding Nicola would be
would be welcoming and helping to move
on from from this incident but
um I think the community has proven
itself to be very strong Community as
you know Sky News has been covering this
story throughout we decided to come up
today to we really focus on on what may
have happened and when you come and have
a look at this obviously I've been
talking about it for a long time looks
pretty innocuous yes yes it does um when
the police first contacted the council
about it they didn't make clear though
that while the river looks very calm on
the surface it is quite strong tidal
current underneath so it does look
innocuous the river does look very calm
very peaceful but that's quite deceiving
and what other involvements have the
council had with the police have you
been able to help them we've tried to
just raise awareness and try and get the
message out to people not to come to St
Michael's
um the local councilors have described
how busy this area has been at the
weekend there's been Lake Windermere on
a busy Summer's Day hundreds of people
and try to discourage people coming to
to somehow carry out their own
investigations which has been happening
and and just to try to stop some of the
more
darker elements of of the Public's
interest in this yeah people being
arrested for going into people's back
Gardens with flash torches at in the
middle of the night haven't you've seen
that there's no houses immediately
around here but Pete houses just nearby
people have reported being sat in their
living rooms in the afternoon watching
television and people coming up to the
windows peering in trying the doors it's
been terrifying for them it's a
typically elderly people
um extremely scared in their own homes
the residents have had to employ an
external security company that's just
not accepted know that yeah okay and how
are they have you spoken to them
um generally local councilors have kept
in regular touch with residents
um again the community have stayed
strong people typically stayed strong
and they've they've been very resilient
in these sort of difficult times and
they do they have found it very
upsetting and very distressing do you
need to look at what you might need to
do to make this a safer place
uh possibly yes uh I think you can
always
um you can always learn lessons from
instance like this obviously the bank is
quite steep it's getting the balance
right though between what is potentially
one terrible incident and people's
access to the river and the ability to
walk into fish and and to do all the
things that they want to do on the
rivers but it is something you're going
to look at yes I mean we we aren't
necessarily responsible for would be
responsible for fencing it off as a
Borough Council but we would wear with
Partners to look at what we can do
across the board to make the river why
I'm all safe for people yes it's good to
talk to you thanks for taking the time
to join us bear with me one second if
you would please thank you well
Lancashire police facing mounting
pressure over its handling of the
investigation after it revealed personal
information about Nicholas struggle with
alcohol and the menopause the Home
Secretary swella Braven has demanded an
explanation Additionally the forces also
referred itself to the Watchdog over
contact its officers had with a 45 year
old before her disappearance on
Wednesday night police revealed that
Nicola bully suffered significant issues
with alcohol which had resurfaced in the
months before she disappeared earlier
this year a response car with police and
health professionals attended her home
following a concern for welfare it's
been revealed that police have now
referred themselves to the independent
Watchdog over the visit two and a half
weeks later Nicola bully disappeared at
some point between 9 10 and 9 33 in the
morning she was reported missing to
police just an hour and a half later
the next day police drones helicopters
and dogs began the search for Nicola
three days into the search Lancashire
police said for the first time that they
did not believe her disappearance was
suspicious
a week after she disappeared police
announced that they were working on the
hypothesis that Nicola had entered the
river a team of underwater dive
Specialists joined police in searching
the river wire but failed to uncover new
evidence following intense public
interest police issued a dispersal order
in Saint Michael's on wire where people
were conducting their own searches
on Wednesday police had a press
conference and revealed that Nicola
bully had specific vulnerabilities which
means that she's classified as a
high-risk missing person just a few
hours later the force revealed personal
details about Nicola including that she
struggled with alcohol issues and with
symptoms of perimenopause Martin and NZ
still with me uh Martin if that was so
important why didn't they tell us to
start with
because it's not the sort of information
about a personal information about a
victim that you would normally disclose
my feeling is that Lancashire police
were so stung by the criticism about the
focus of their investigation which was
that Nicola had gone into the water
rather than have been the victim of a
crime that they um
they invaded the privacy of her family
and of her in order to save its own
reputation I think that's what's
happened I mean they began at the press
conference by talking about her
vulnerabilities without going into
any great detail which I think was fair
enough but why on Earth three or four
hours later they put out that
astonishing statement that went into
real real detail about alcohol problems
menopause concerns
um is is beyond me and Beyond most
commentators I mean the force has been
widely condemned by all sorts of people
and I think there's even a sense that
the family although the family must have
known did know that some of this
information was going to come out I
think even they were astonished at the
reaction that it's provoked and perhaps
with hindsight think well maybe the
police shouldn't have put those kind of
details out and they certainly feel
Nicola wouldn't have wanted yeah and the
shadow Home Secretary and the Home
Secretary both wanting answers
yes Lancashire police are under the cost
um I mean they're being investigated or
they may be investigated over their
initial contact with Nicola and her
family on the 10th of January we've
already talked about you know the
welfare concern that Drew police and
health professionals to the house 17
days later Nicola vanishes so it's um
it's standard practice really that the
police Watchdog the iopc would look at
what happened on the 10th of January to
see if the police did everything they
could to see if there's a connection
with what the police did or didn't do on
the 10th of January and Nicholas
disappearance on the 27th and the Home
Secretary quite rightly wants to know
why police said what they said two days
ago interesting to hear from the council
leader saying we need to look at this
whether it's safe or not and they're
definitely going to investigate it yeah
well I think that is something you know
working on the police's main hypothesis
that you know this is the area that
Nicola ended up in the water then
clearly it is something that they're
going to have to look at this
but you know we have seen dog walkers by
the dozens and dozens over the last
three weeks it's heavily populated with
dog walkers uh obviously a small village
but people come from far and wide to
walk their dog here it's a it is a
beautiful part of the world there's no
denying that but clearly there is an
issue by this bench it's very muddy here
it would be very very easy to slip and
okay I don't know if you can actually
see but in the river
there are parts of the river where there
is some un quite disconcerting uh
whirlpools of water that signifies that
there are quite deep parts of the water
of the river wire here as well so you
know a huge worry if it is the case that
Nicola ended up in the water if I make a
I've been speaking to Nicola's family
all throughout the last three weeks I
interviewed her sister her Mum and Dad
just days after she went missing Sky
News has also heard from her partner
Paul as well
um but a note coming in from her father
um whilst he's watching this morning he
says we've had an incredibly hard few
days
um and it is just fingers crossed that
what we're doing today raising awareness
of Nicholas still missing three weeks on
helps them get some answers but that is
a family still really struggling to come
to terms with Nicola being missing for
three weeks now okay I know you're going
to be with me throughout the morning
gentlemen for now thanks so much indeed
also still to come on the program for
you speaking to Simon Harding a former
met police detective Chief Inspector for
his assessment on how Lancashire police
are handling the investigation and
nurses are escalating their industrial
action with more strikes next month
speaking to Chief exec of NHS providers
sir Julian Hartley and at just after
eight speaking to Labor's Shadow foreign
secretary David Lammy
we'll have all the latest from Saint
Michael's on Wyatt throughout the
morning but first let's take a look at
some of today's other news for you and
some breaking news in the last few
moments the latest retail sales figures
show retail sales volumes increased by a
half of one percent in January after a
fall of 1.2 percent in December of 2022
the RS says the rise was driven by
January sales promotions for online and
non-food sales though the cost of living
and food prices continue to hit food
sales
and some more breaking news this morning
NatWest has revealed its profits surge
by more than a third to reach 5.1
billions last year as it ramped up
mortgage lending and took in more income
amid higher interest rates
the Royal College of Nursing has
announced its biggest walkout of the pay
dispute in England the union has said no
services will be exempt meaning the
strike will involve for the first time
nursing staff working in emergency
departments intensive care units Cancer
Care and other services let's get more
with Becky joining us from the
University College Hospital Becky good
morning
yeah it's a dramatic escalation okay as
you mentioned nurses working in a e
departments in Cancer Care they will be
striking and NHS leaders have
understandably expressed their alarm at
this now previously because of
industrial action in the NHS uh since
the end of last year around 140 000
appointments have been canceled that is
nothing to be taken lightly but this
time you could see patients in need of
potentially life-saving treatment in
need of Cancer Care and that care is in
Jeopardy now the nurses Union have said
they will provide life and limb cover
they are in discussions with the
government about what that will look
like but they have said that they will
provide the absolute minimum Staffing
and they have said that the NHS should
look to other clinical professions other
unions to cover for them but even if
that cover is in place this strike could
have potentially deadly consequences for
patients now this of course has all come
about because talks between the Union
and the government about pay and working
conditions are not getting anywhere the
Royal College of Nursing has accused the
prime minister of refusing to negotiate
and we're seeing similar things across
the public sector but of course with
nurses with NHS staff the stakes are so
much higher if you've got patients
showing up in need of urgent care and
that care might be in jeopardy
okay for no thank you well the Scottish
national party says it will announce its
new leader on the 27th of March after
the surprise resignation of the first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon no one has
officially thrown their hats in the ring
yet but several candidates have ruled
themselves out of the race including the
snp's Westminster leader Stephen Flynn
Deputy first Minister John Swinney and
SMP Joanna Cherry according to reports
the Scottish Health secretary Hanzo
Youssef is considering entering the race
Mr Youssef is the first non-white and
first Muslim cabinet minister in the
Scottish government
which is in our kids in Northern Ireland
today amid growing speculation he could
be close to securing an improved
post-brexit deal with the EU it's
understood the PM will meet political
parties to discuss fixing the Practical
problems on the ground our political
correspondent Rob Pyle has them all Rob
yeah this certainly looks okay like we
are in the end game here of this lengthy
protracted process to try and find some
sort of settlement to fix some of the
issues relating to Northern Ireland that
stem from the brexit deal that was
signed by Boris Johnson Rishi sunak and
his Northern Ireland secretary flew to
Belfast last night they'll have meetings
today with political parties and other
involved groups Richie sunak will then
fly on to Germany to Munich tomorrow
where there's likely to be more meetings
with European leaders at the same time
the foreign secretary James cleverley is
heading to Brussels today for meetings
with EU leaders so all the parts look to
be moving into place I think the most
critical meetings the most important
meetings which is sunak Will arguably
have today will be with the dup unionist
politicians in Northern Ireland who are
refusing to allow storm on the devolved
assembly in Belfast to sit in protest at
what they see as Northern Ireland being
carved away from the rest of the United
Kingdom as a result of that brexit deal
if those Democratic institutions are to
get up and running in Belfast again
Rishi sunak will need to get the dup
um on board he will also though need to
square his conservative
um back benches so yes big practical
issues to solve as well but big
political issues and big political risks
for Rishi sunak as well
thank you
the Hollywood star Bruce Willis has been
diagnosed with frontotemporal dementia
according to his family they took social
media to they took to social media I
should say to announce how his condition
had Advanced a 67 year old Die Hard
actor announced he was stepping back
from his career after being diagnosed in
March of 2022 with a fascia a condition
affecting the brain which causes
difficulty with language and with speech
coming up after the break we'll have the
latest from Saint Michael's on wire
three weeks to the day since The
Disappearance of mum of two Nicola bully
[Music]
foreign
hello again everybody welcome back to St
Michael's on why we're bringing you a
special program this morning three weeks
to the day since Nicola bully
disappeared NC is with me as you can see
bitterly cold this morning as it was
that day it was it was really cold that
Friday the 27th of January
um it was you know a winter morning it
was muddy here as it is quite often
actually but this is a route you know
covered by many many dog walkers and
it's a route that nickel a bully took
pretty much almost every day we saw some
CCTV images uh from her front house the
ring doorbell showed her leaving the
house putting the the dog Willow
daughters into the car she then set off
around 10-minute Journey from in skip
dropped her kids off at school and then
went on her daily routine of taking
Willow for a walk and she would end up
around here that morning she was on a
team's call with her uh with her company
that she works for as a mortgage advisor
and then what happened in a 10-minute
window an unaccounted 10-minute window
which police are still trying to get
questions over is the huge question
right now three weeks on what happened
to Nicola bully in that 10 minute window
yeah I know the family have been
speaking to you this morning I've also
um had the local Council leader on the
program he was saying they're going to
look at here I mean it looks pretty
innocuous but once you get into that
River it is tidal and it's it could be
up to 20 feet deep in places so he says
we're going to look at what can be done
to try and sort that out it's an
important point that as well okay
because you know over the last three
weeks a lot of people said oh well I
don't you know it doesn't really seem
it's flowing fast it looks quite calm
but actually it's a tidal reverse so the
nature of it means that it moves back
and forth constantly and police but
adamant that you know that is the case
if say Nicola went into that River as
their working hypothesis is she will
have moved significantly in 21 days and
potentially well highly likely police
actually say is that she would have
ended out at Sea when you just go round
the bend here the Meander of the river
wire here you get to a wear the wear
then picks up a lot of stream and you
see the water starts moving pretty
quickly and then when we've gone you
know further down the river as it gets
wider and wider you see it moving really
quickly in some parts the water going
Upstream in some parts going Downstream
and you see big pieces of debris moving
in that water as well so the police have
been scouring that water using water
drones using divers specialist diving
teams they've used boats on the water as
well on underwater cameras to really get
a sense if they can find any evidence in
relating to Nicola going missing yeah
also hearing for the local councilor
that local
households have had to employ private
security because people have been trying
their doors knocking on Windows and
there's been an awful lot of interest in
what is happening here we've just had a
statement from lancashire's police and
crime commissioner that is Andrew
Snowden he says first and foremost my
thoughts remain with the family and
friends of Nicola buddy and I'm thankful
for all the efforts of the officers
staff and partners who continue to work
tirelessly on the search for Nicola
the investigation Into The Disappearance
of Nicola is under the direction and
control of the chief Constable the
unprecedented we haven't heard from him
by the way the unprecedented media and
public interest in this case whilst
welcome for appeals for information is
challenging for the family and friends
of Nicola and officers and police staff
dealing with unsubstantiated rumors and
speculation on a daily basis I'd like to
thank all members of the public Who
provided helpful information to
Lancashire police the police are being
as transparent as they can be on what is
an incredibly sensitive and complex case
that includes continued external support
from the National Crime agency and
others as appropriate joining us now
former met police detective Chief
Inspector Simon Harding
um hello to you thank you for joining us
on the program
um your thoughts on how this case has
been handled by Lancashire police over
the last three weeks
well I think I think it does sort of
look at two Avenues really one is the
the messaging which has probably caused
I mean what you could Now call a bit of
a circus really isn't it around
um Everybody turning up and uh and and
speculation in in some parts of uh the
media and some and and a lot of people
on Tick Tock and all those various
social media channels but what you
really want to see is is that the
investigation in the background is being
conducted properly and there is there is
some doubt around that as well
unfortunately simply because originally
when the three hypothesis came out that
which is quite right from the detective
superintendent
Smith that you that you she could be
either in the river which is which is
still true she could still be in the
river that's you know everyone should
understand that that's one of the
hypotheses and also she could have left
of her own accord that area and we now
know uh from the the uh press conference
on Wednesday that that there is a
possibility there are Roots out of there
which
um are not covered by CCTV so and I
think it within the actual press
conference itself the superintendent did
mention that it just the day before that
press conference that they'd identified
a path which um is that doesn't have
that sort of coverage and and is a
possible route out now that that was a
slight worry because obviously the area
hasn't been
uh cold and off as we say and so you
know those those are the routes in the
past that you would want probably
fingertip searches on just to just to
make sure so everything should still be
on the table all those hypothesis
and and probably the the the reason why
it's gone a little bit array for them is
because it just felt like they were
pushing into just one of those three
yeah I mean I walked down that path
actually this morning and I wasn't aware
until
um a couple of days ago that there was
no CCTV that was covering uh that path
or the entrance or exit to it I wondered
why the dog wouldn't have followed her
if she'd walked along the path but there
is a kissing gate here so potentially
the dog wouldn't have been able to get
through if she'd wanted him to stay
behind but the police are still
confident that their working hypothesis
is that she stumbled down the bank
behind us here or in some other way
found herself in the water
yeah and I think you know that's it's
it's phraseology sometimes you know the
work the sort of phrase we use about an
open mind uh is that everything is on
the table until you can actually take it
off the table so if you have direct
evidence factual evidence that that she
has gone in the river then of course
that would be your
um your main one but
um I think because they're suggesting
that there isn't evidence that she's
she's left uh or been taken by a third
party for example then that's why those
are still on the table however there's
as much evidence of that than that that
she's left her own accord through that
pathway for example then there is that
she's gone into the river so I'm sure
they are and I can see that they are
doing lots and lots of work in the
background and having the NCAA as
they've said uh by this side and other
partners who will be helping is a is a
reassurance in in some part too
okay um should we have seen more from
the chief constable
well it's not for me to say really but I
mean I think the person that I always
wanted to speak you know or hear from
brother was um the sio because you know
having been an sio I always think that
the family wants to see you because
you're the person you're the you're the
front and center of this and and those
are the people I want to see quite often
when you have those almost like
figureheads of the assistant chief
constable and the chief Constable come
out it's more of a corporate reassurance
and and top cover as they call it but
you know you want you want the person
that's dealing with a day in day out of
the inquiry and obviously the chief
Constable won't be doing that but
they'll be being briefed as I'm sure now
uh members of parliament are being
briefed as well uh on a daily basis of
any developments that might happen due
to the nature of how this is uh how this
has grown
and would you have been comfortable
releasing the sort of information that
we have heard about Nicola over the last
couple of days
no I don't think I would have done it
but I think that's that's probably down
to that original media strategy where
you're almost justifying why you know on
a personal level and as a team level why
you believe more than anything else that
she's in the river and I don't think
that was necessary if you if your
original strategy is just that you give
weight to all three of those scenarios
then of course people were expecting you
as as part of one of those to be in the
river they'll be expecting you to get
CCTV and you can get in dash cams you
don't then have to elude you know you
know in the background what your
favorite one is
because of her background but
um you wouldn't necessarily have to have
pushed it into the public Arena and I
yeah I think that's probably uh the
worst thing that's come out of this now
especially talking about alcoholism for
example linked with the menopause I mean
you know there was nothing to suggest
that she was uh drunk or anything that
morning you know having driven her kids
to school and uh went through her
routine and met people and uh logged on
to calls and arranged dates and all
those sort of things so so the necessity
the necessity of saying that is probably
for me
um unnecessary
okay it's good to talk to you thanks for
joining us thank you Martin's still with
us
um we're here three weeks on
um no sign of her hasn't been for um the
whole three weeks the dog was here the
phone was here the lead was here
where'd the police go from here they
continue to search
um you know it's difficult to see them
ever bringing a halt to the search but I
guess inevitably they will um get to a
point where they will stop the search
this may be many weeks off
and then leave the case open and be
prepared to react when any new
information or evidence comes forward
but yeah we may be a long way from that
I mean at the moment you know for all
the control controversy they've stirred
up over the way they've handled it in a
media sense they say they are absolutely
determined to carry on the search they
still as far as we know have 40
detectives working on the case and
perhaps as many as 20 other officers
they still have a range of experts
search teams available to them so at the
moment there doesn't appear to be any
let up in their Endeavors to find Nicola
but they don't think that there will
find your life
I think hopes of that happening must be
fading very fast and I think also for
her family they must be coming to coming
round to the idea that perhaps they
aren't going to see her alive again but
I mean the important thing for the
family is that they've been shown no
evidence there is no evidence that she's
even come to any harm so they will as we
all would in those circumstances cling
to the hope
you know in the absence of any bad
evidence that she is for whatever reason
somewhere alive
and there is that area that we will walk
along um later on that doesn't have CCTV
coverage so she could have moved away
from the bank without being seen
in theory yes but as far as the police
are concerned they have no evidence no
information
that she left the riverbank which is why
the very strong focus of their
investigation is that she stayed within
this area
and
extrapolating from that their theory is
again not backed by any hard evidence
that she went into the water and it's
interesting the language the police have
used I'm not aware they've ever talked
about an accident or her falling into
the water given what they've already
said now about the state of her mind you
know her personal issues and clearly
their focus is on the idea that for some
reason tied up with perhaps her mental
health issues that Nicola perhaps
decided to end her life that's where the
focus is but again there's no evidence
of that there is not for now Martin
thanks so much Martin again going to be
with us throughout the morning as we
focus on this part of the river while
were three weeks ago at Nicola bully was
last seen she has not been seen since in
a statement the family has said she has
been had been struggling with symptoms
of perimenopause including brain fog and
Restless sleep it's after criticism over
the decision of Lancashire police to
disclose very personal information
Ashner has been looking at the impact
the menopause can have
like millions of women Nicola bully had
been coping with the adverse effects of
the perimenopause details shared by her
family remind us all of the physical and
mental strain it can have but also of
the lack of awareness
for many people it comes as a surprise
and a shock
um because it can be very varied but
also we have a situation where for some
of our particularly some of our GPS our
practice nurses Unfortunately they have
never had formal education about
menopause the menopause happens when
women's periods stop usually between the
ages of 45 to 55 but can start earlier
there are over 30 symptoms including
insomnia and night sweats but these
hormone changes can impact mental health
too for one in Four Women the symptoms
are debilitating and for women with
perimenopause they can happen up to a
year before the menstrual cycle stops
Nicola Billy's family say that she had
been struggling with the perimenopause
and had started taking HRT to try and
cope but that in itself started causing
some severe side effects it's a reminder
that whilst this is a widely available
treatment that can be effective at
relieving symptoms for some for others
it can have a very different impact
the women's and equalities committee has
long argued that not enough is being
done to protect menopausal women
we know that the menopause will affect
different people in different ways for
some it will be much more severe than
others and I think the real challenge
around the menopause is that people are
given adequate medical support and
assistance from professionals and not
stigmatized
solving those challenges means tackling
that stigma famous faces have been
campaigning for the cause for years
until their voices are heard for half
the population it may continue to feel
like a silent struggle Ashley Sky News
still to come I'm going to be speaking
to the chief of the NHS providers after
the Royal College of Nursing announced a
significant escalation in strike action
we're also going to have the very latest
from here Saint Michael's on wire three
weeks to the day since Nicola bully
disappeared
foreign
[Music]
use Midlands correspondent based here in
Birmingham
allegations of exploitation in
leicester's clothing factories aren't
new in fact it's been an Open Secret in
this city for years
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain world
we're getting more and more stabbings
and essentially I think it's more
younger children here in the diverse
Industrial
restaurant we hear from
people of real stories to tell
parents are going to complain like this
these protests are being organized
primarily by people who aren't parents
at the school
we have to be prepared that patients
will die from from this illness
the river seven is still rising and
people here in Ironbridge have been told
it could go up by another meter
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
foreign
everyone it's three weeks uh since month
two Nicola bully disappeared um at this
spot here on the river wide it's about
an extensive search by Lancashire police
involving more than 40 detectives hours
and hours of CCTV conversations with up
to 700 drivers dog walkers who use this
path regularly there has been no sign of
Nicola we'll have continuing coverage
throughout the morning and we will
retrace the steps and the walk that she
took from the school car park where she
dropped her two daughters off to the
point where her phone was left on a
bench still connected to a call
what's happened to her nobody seems to
know at this stage continuing coverage
as I said here on Sky
meantime the Royal College of Nursing
has announced its biggest walkout today
Nurses at half of hospitals mental
health and Community Services will take
part in the 48-hour strike from the
first to the 3rd of March the union has
said no services will be exempt meaning
that for the first time the strike will
involve nursing staff working in
emergency departments intensive care
units Cancer Care and other services
joining us now is the chief exec of NHS
providers sir Julian Hartley hello to
you sir Julian thank you for joining us
it's getting serious now
yeah it's it really is uh serious
um very very worrying obviously in terms
of the potential impact uh the scale of
this is more extensive with 93 trusts
involved the duration 48 hours including
overnight and of course as you have said
the fact that the derogations have
changed that's the exemption so you know
for example itu
um obviously itu is a key area in in any
major hospital it's all about not just
major trauma but of course very
important operations Cardiac Care uh
neurosurgery
cancer surgery and of course emergency
departments and Cancer Care as well so
although the RCN have said uh they plan
to work at a national level to make sure
that there is life preserving care uh
trust leaders I know are extremely
concerned and worried about the
potential impact for patients on on this
uh this next round of action
and it's not just that
the naughty eight hours it's 48 Hours
continuously what we saw previously was
nurses going on strike for 12 hours and
then coming back to work how concerned
are you that you are going to be able to
cope
well there'll be a huge amount of
planning now uh we'll kick in there'll
be all of the work to think about
contingencies and how we do protect
patient safety and care but obviously as
you say the fact it's overnight as well
so the Intensive monitoring for example
of patients that goes on continuously
night and day finding ways to make sure
that that's managed and
um taken care of that there are so many
logistical practical challenges
not just actually in hospitals but
across the whole of the NHS in other
organizations as well that are affected
obviously in Community Services mental
health and so on so this is really quite
a significant development and I know
plus will be working hard to protect
patients but the other thing to say of
course is there'll be a significant
amount of care disrupted so planned
operations we've already seen a hundred
and forty thousand
um Admissions outpatients and so on
being disrupted and we're likely to see
another large number at a time when the
NHS is driving towards reducing the
backlog of patients waiting for hair and
treatment and so it's a it's a key time
for us to focus on those priorities
which I know everyone in the service
wants to do
and what's your advice to people who are
concerned either for themselves or their
loved ones who may well be using the
services of the National Health Service
during those 48 hours
well people should still attend as usual
unless they hear otherwise trusts will
do everything they can to manage and
mitigate the risks there is likely to be
disruption and patients should wait to
hear from their hospital if if that's
the case if they don't hear anything
they should attend as normal but
obviously over the coming days there'll
be a lot more work I know at a national
level to work with the RCN to look at
that issue of derogations and where
um where that ends up but that's I just
emphasize that um trusts will be doing
everything they can to try to work
through this to protect patient safety
that is absolutely the top priority
good to talk to you thanks for taking
the time thank you thank you
three weeks ago today
Nicola Bully's phone was found on that
bench the dog's lead was found on the
bench the dog was here Willow running
around but there was no sign of Nicola
bully if we look from our other camera
you can see the river wire it's um it's
a beauty spot it's where a lot of dog
walkers come she had seen quite a few
dog walkers who well certainly they have
contacted the police to say yeah we saw
her she was doing this she was in the
upper field she was in the lower field
but what happened to her before 10
o'clock since that day there has been
absolutely no sign of Nicola her family
are out of their minds worrying about
where she is she's a mum she's a partner
she's a sister she's a daughter and
they've waited and waited to try to
discover her fate the police say that
they feel that she entered the river the
family say that is not what has happened
and they just want to come home
continuing coverage here on Sky
[Music]
foreign
thank you
good morning everyone it is eight
o'clock we're live this morning in Saint
Michael's on wire for a special program
exactly three weeks since Nicola bully
dropped her children off at school took
the dog for a walk along the river y
behind me and then simply vanished as
her family call for the public to focus
on finding up we'll retrace Nicola's
last no movements as they happened later
this hour and the magic criticism for
Lancashire police after it revealed
personal information about Nicholas
struggle with alcohol and the menopause
now the Home Secretary has weighed in
it's Friday the 17th of February
three weeks and still no answers Nicola
Bully's family called for an end to
speculation and rumors and plea for help
to find him
the Home Secretary demands an
explanation from Lancashire police after
it revealed personal details about
Nicholas struggle with alcohol and the
menopause
the force refers itself to the police
Watchdog over contact its officers had
with the mum of two before she
disappeared
we'll retrace Nicholas steps this
morning as they happened on Friday three
weeks ago
also coming up nurses escalate their
industrial action announcing a fresh
48-hour strike the Royal College of
Nursing says no area will be exempt
Deal or No Deal the prime minister is in
Northern Ireland amid growing
speculation that a breakthrough on
post-brexit trading Arrangements is
imminent
the first candidates expected to
formally enter the running to become
Scotland's new first Minister as the SNP
reveals how the race will unfold
I'm the Hollywood Superstar Bruce Willis
has been diagnosed with frontotemporal
dementia
[Music]
morning and welcome to a special program
live from Saint Michaels on why in
Lancashire it's now exactly three weeks
since Nicola bully was last seen after
dropping her children off at school and
taking the dog for a walk the mum of
two's family have issued a fresh plea
for the public to focus on finding her
and to end the speculation about her
private life after Lancashire police
revealed personal details about her
including issues with alcohol and the
menopause the forces coming under
growing criticism about those
disclosures with even the Home Secretary
swella bravaman now demanding answers
we'll be live here throughout the
morning looking at the circumstances
surrounding her disappearance and later
in the show will follow the same walk
the 45 year old took on that Friday
morning three weeks ago
Lindsay is uh here with me three weeks
no sign well let's think about it okay
let's take it back three weeks ago what
Nicola would have been doing this
morning getting her two daughters up
getting them ready for school getting
her dog Willow ready to take out for a
walk this is all that would be going on
three weeks ago today on the 27th of
January she did all that it was routine
for her a mom of two she took the girls
to school she dropped them off she went
and took Willow for a walk and then
there were 10 minutes 10 minutes
unaccounted for which police which her
family which members of the public are
very tight-knit Community here in St
Michael's on wire do not know what
happened to Nicola bully and the last
three weeks has been
not only absolutely hellish for the
family but it has brought the best of
this community in a way we have seen
this community band together come out in
full force searching for Nicola dog
walkers coming together to see if they
can find any traces of evidence to find
the mum of two but it is also revealed
and I think many would say and we've
heard the criticism of Lancashire police
some flaws in an investigation there are
still many questions over how Lancashire
police have conducted this investigation
particularly their Communications but
the bigger question remains is where is
Nicola bully did she fall into this very
cold often very deep river which moves
back and forth very quickly off this
steep muddy bank because you know
looking at it I'm a dog walker and I
would have if I was walking past here I
would have no fear of of what is
happening there and we're told that it's
only two feet deep if you fall in here
or if you get into the water it's two
feet deep here but it's tidal yeah and
look if you walk if you did this route
every single day you know of course
you're not going to be worried by the
steepness of the bank and how muddy it
is you know you're used to it but on the
edge yes it's about two three feet deep
there are a lot of rocks and and Stones
there as well but okay I've seen divers
go into this River over the last three
weeks and as you go into the center of
this part of the river wire there is a
huge drop around 15 to 20 feet a lot of
fish local fishermen tell us as well
there are whirlpools we can see this
morning of the river as well that
suggests that there are some deep parts
of the rivers you can see there but
clearly you know it is an innocuous area
it's an area which the police will have
looked at extensively over the last
three weeks and not just here on this
corner but further Downstream as well
they will have looked at many parts of
the river and of course the mouth and
into the sea as well where police
believe if she has fallen into the water
that's where it's highly likely she's
ended up What secrets does this Bend in
the river hold that's what the police
want to know that's what her family want
to know she disappeared let me tell you
a little bit more about the timeline she
disappeared on Friday morning exactly
three weeks ago later this hour will be
retracing Nicole's steps but first let's
take a look at what we know so far
excuse me from the police about her
movements that morning Nicola went
missing early on the 27th of Jan after
traveling from her home in Inskip around
the corner really to the nearby Village
of Saint Michael's on wire she dropped
her children off at school in the
village on garstang road Nicola then set
off on her usual walk with her dog
Willow of 8 43 a.m along the river wire
footpath a dog walker who was familiar
with Nicholas saw her walking around the
lower field
at approximately 8 50. we'll show you
that in a bit 853 she used her mobile
phone to send an email to her boss then
at 901 Nicola logged into a team's call
for work but approximately 10 past 9 a
witness somebody who also knows Nicholas
saw her on the upper field walking her
dog 9 20 her phone moved towards the
bench area behind me and towards the
lower field at around half past nine the
team's call ended but Nicola stayed
logged on Nicola's mobile phone and her
dog Willow were found nearby on the
bench behind me next to the river by
another dog walker at approximately
09.33 let me just show you that bench um
behind me here so that it's a spot where
her phone was found the dog was running
around here his lead her lead was on the
bench there but what has happened to
Nicola we're going to be talking about
that and we're going to retrace her
steps for you uh in the next 45 minutes
or so at meantime let's bring in David
love me should we he is the foreign the
shadow foreign secretary for now uh
speaking to us on behalf of the labor
party this morning I know that we're
going to talk about lots of other things
let me just talk about what's Happening
Here I know that you're a family man and
your heart must go out to the family
oh it's awful
um and it was hugely surprising
to hear those personal details uh about
Nicola bully revealed uh in the way that
they were
um I think that all of us are praying
and hoping that she's out there you want
to have a call out for her to return to
her family
notwithstanding what's been said about
her and my heart goes out to her
daughters particularly who must be
hugely hugely distressed not having
their Mummy at home
yeah we spoke to Yvette Cooper actually
yesterday she wanted some answers from
Lancashire police about the information
that they had released about her
your view on that
I it's unclear to me why this
information was pertinent and important
to the investigation and how it leads to
her return
um and so like so many members of the
public I'm surprised that this has
happened in this way the important thing
now
um is that she's found
um and that she's returned to her family
talk to me um about the boss going to uh
Kiev yesterday what was all that about
well look I think it is important
to
underlie very very clearly the cross
party support for the Ukrainian people
at this time particularly as they
prepare for what looks like a spring
offensive and more aggression from Putin
and his troops and his forces here in
the United Kingdom the labor party the
conservatives all of the opposition has
stood shoulder to shoulder with the
people of Ukraine to support them
militarily uh politically diplomatically
and economically at this very very
difficult time and I'm here in Munich as
the global Community gathers and number
one on the agenda is to ensure that the
ukrainians Prevail and that we assist
them in that effort
but isn't that the prime minister's job
rather than the leader of the opposition
oh look I mean just as it was right for
kirstama to go to Northern Ireland a few
weeks ago to be in Davos a few weeks ago
of course it's right that in the biggest
foreign policy challenge of our time
that he's meeting uh zelenski for the
second time and being absolutely clear
that if there was to be a change of
government and we would expect the next
the next election at some point next
year that that support for Ukraine would
continue and I'm pleased that um
zielinski indicated that he's very
grateful for that
uh you bring up Northern Ireland Shadow
foreign Secretary of course that's where
the prime minister is going to be today
to try and sort out these challenges
still surrounding brexit I hear that
labor say that they will be supporting
the government
um I wonder if there are any Riders uh
in relation
um to that what is it that you're
actually supporting them in
okay you will recall that the
significant issue facing Rishi sunak is
in fact with his own back benches and
the ERG particularly uh who have found
big issue with the European court of
justice as the final Court of dispute
that would deal with the issues that
might arise as a result of differences
over those Customs check we have been
very clear and here set this out a few
weeks ago when he was in Northern
Ireland
um that we will support the government
to get uh this through to take this off
the table and the reason we'll do that
because we believe that it's in the
interests of Northern Ireland all
communities in Northern Ireland that
they now have certainty in relation to
these issues and that we can move
forward and so for that reason if he
needs the votes from labor we will
support it
um okay so that there aren't any Riders
there if they go ahead with what has
already been discussed they've got your
complete backing
they do have our backing uh we're clear
on that
okay talk to me about why you're in
Munich today
well look I think that there are three
issues facing the global community that
uh that we gather for one of course is
Ukraine that we've discussed the second
is China these spy balloons aggression
in the Taiwan Straits and the third is
Iran and their desire for nuclear
capability over this next period so this
is a dangerous moment I'm here to bring
the message that we believe that the
United Kingdom has to be reconnected in
the global Community reconnected with
our allies to deal with these big issues
to bring that message about how a labor
government would approach these issues
to meet with world leaders but to
underline and to speak about the
challenges that are facing not just our
own economy but many economies across
the globe because all foreign policy at
this time
um is domestic when we see the fights on
energy the fights on climate uh
migration all foreign policy comes back
to domestic policy and the security and
prosperity of our people in the United
Kingdom
okay um safe journey back home thanks so
much indeed as always thank you
Rob standing by for us Rob your thoughts
yeah it's fascinating isn't it hey that
David Lammy uh not too long ago a few
years ago maybe was a pretty vocal
campaigner for another referendum and
for remain to be an option in another
brexit referendum now labor essentially
saying that they will back the
government in any sort of deal that they
strike with the EU to take that question
and take that tension around Northern
Ireland and brexit
um off the table so the opposition here
won't be really providing the opposing
voice that will likely come from
backbench conservative MPS who are
worried about the government doing too
many compromises with the EU especially
over the role of European courts in
Northern Ireland and it will likely come
as well from the dup Northern Irish
politicians who are concerned about the
current brexit deal and how they see it
as carving out Northern Ireland from the
rest of the United Kingdom it's those
two groups that Richard sunac will need
to win over if there is a brexit deal to
be done in the coming days labor saying
that essentially it will back the
government to do a deal whatever it puts
on the table
okay for now thank you
um back here
um to Lancashire my home County uh very
much in the news over the last three
weeks because of Nicola bully and the
way that the police have been dealing
with this investigation Martin run
lots of controversy um as far as the
investigation is going um Lancashire
police may be doing a you know a very
very thorough job I mean clearly they
haven't found Nicola but there's an
awful lot of work going on but it's
really their
their media strategy that's come under
Fire the Revelation for no obvious
reason about Nicholas personal problems
her health issues I say no obvious
reason but I think the perception is and
a very wide perception that the force
two days ago
seem to be blaming her victim blaming to
cover up their own shortfalls they were
stung by the criticism that they perhaps
were too much focused on the idea that
she'd gone into the river which the
family don't really accept
and wanted to in some way try and
restore
people's confidence in what they were
doing and you know perhaps it goes to
the wider issue that we've been talking
about for the last two years about this
growing lack of confidence and Trust in
British policing you know perhaps this
What's Happening Here is in some way
indicative of the public losing trust in
the way police do things and it's it's
become easier perhaps in that wider
context to doubt what the experts say
and do just looking at a couple of dog
walkers as we uh we're standing
um here um
was nothing out of the uh normal was it
really I mean she was she dropped her
kids off at school and she'd come to do
this walk that she'd probably done
hundreds if not thousands of times
before family are confident that she's
still alive the police are saying she
went into the river and they don't think
she came out again
interesting that the family said a few
days ago that it wasn't her habit to
walk near the river
and you know you have to sort of keep
coming back
to the idea that and even the police
admit this there's no evidence really of
anything
that might explain what happened to her
and in the absence of anything that
suggests she's even come to any harm her
family will like all of us would cling
to the hope that there is perhaps a
possibility however vague that she is
still alive she's somewhere she might
even be watching the news coverage but
and part of the statement they said
yesterday was look you know don't be
scared you know come back come home
we're all waiting for you they cling to
that hope and who wouldn't indeed so
let's bring in Palm Sandu former met
police chief superintendent hello to you
thanks for joining us on the program
um your thoughts on this case
good morning
um from what I can see the police force
itself have actually put a lot of
resources a lot of people into this
investigation you know they've got
drones they've got underwater search
teams they've got a dedicated team of 40
or 50 officers who are looking at all
the leads of the public bring them and
as Martin has just said the only place
that they have failed is in their
Communications where they haven't
communicated properly with either the
public or the family and making the
revelations yesterday about deeply
personal issues for Nicola to you know
making that topic to everyone I just
can't see why they did that and
especially as I know that they didn't
tell the search teams that because that
may have influenced how the search teams
conducted their searches so I can't see
any reason why that was shared with
members of the public
what about the comments
um
that she was struggling with the
menopause and with misuse of alcohol
well I don't see how that helps the
investigation three weeks on or 20 days
on sharing that sort of information with
members of the public because you know
going through menopause is a private
matter it's also you know very troubling
for some women and to have that shared
with the public because what I what I'm
thinking is there's a family at the
center of this there are two little
girls and there's a family these stories
are always going to be there they're
going to grow up with these stories
about their mother you know whether
she's found or not and we you know there
needs to be some sort of respect for
that family and there doesn't seem to be
any and and as quite rightly said trust
and confidence in policing has
deteriorated and that's why people are
questioning what the police are doing
what they have done and The credibility
of what they've done and that's where it
appears that the police in this case are
almost justifying their actions or their
inaction and and it just seems to be a
very defensive sort of maneuver and I
really cannot see why they shared that
information
and they've referred themselves to the
investigation committee for the police
now haven't they not for that but for an
incident that happened a couple of weeks
before
Nicola disappeared when they were called
to her property
yes that's right so there was some
um
action 10 days or about two and a half
weeks before I think it's on the 10th of
January where they actually attended the
address and had a conversation with
Nicola and with her partner and as a
result of it where no one was arrested
no one was dealt with at the time they
have referred themselves for that
investigation by the independent office
so we'll we'll have to wait and see what
happens with that referral
okay thank you for talking to us this
morning thank you we have heard from uh
Nicola's family they've said it's now
been three weeks since Nikki went
missing we as a family believe that the
public Focus has become distracted from
finding Nikki and more about speculation
and rumors into her and Paul's private
life due to the perimenopause Nikki
suffered with significant side effects
such as brain fog Restless sleep and was
taking HRT to help but this was giving
her intense headaches which caused Nikki
to stop taking the HRT thinking that may
have helped her but only ended up
causing this crisis the public Focus has
to be on finding it and not making up
wild theories about her personal life
well coming up later this hour we are
going to retrace the steps of Nicola
three weeks ago today
um and so do stay tuned for more on that
first let's look at some of today's
other headlines for you though
and latest figures show retail sales
volumes increase by 0.5 in January after
a fall of 1.2 in December the ons says
the rise was driven by January sales
promotions for online and non-food sales
so the cost of living and food prices
continue to hit food sales
also this morning British Banking giant
Nat West has revealed its profits surge
by more than a third to reach 5.1
million pounds last year as it ramped up
mortgage lending and uh took in more
income amid higher interest rates
the Hollywood star Bruce Willis has been
diagnosed with frontotemporal dementia
according to his family they took to
social media to announce how his
condition has advanced the 67 year old
Die Hard actor announced he was stepping
back from his career after being
diagnosed in March of 2022 with a fascia
a condition affecting the brain which
causes difficulty with language and also
with speech
Rishi sunak is in Northern Ireland today
amid growing speculation he could be
close to securing an improved
post-brexit deal with the EU it's
understood the PM will meet political
parties to discuss fixing the Practical
problems on the ground our senior Island
correspondent David Blevins joining us
now hello David what are you expecting
today
well we've entered what one newspaper is
describing as a period of frenetic
diplomacy now the prime minister is in
Northern Ireland for various meetings
with political leaders the foreign
secretary James cleverley is in Brussels
for a meeting with the European
commission vice president Mario sefkovic
and then Rishi sunak will travel to
Munich for a security Summit at which
he's expected to meet EU leaders on the
fringes and all of that is signaling
that we are now closer than ever to a
breakthrough on the contentious Northern
Ireland protocol just to remind people
the protocol was the bespoke part of the
brexit withdrawal agreement which dealt
with the complication of Northern
Ireland sharing a land border with the
Republic of Ireland which of course
remains part of the European Union to
avoid any checks here on this island
Boris Johnson and the EU agreed to the
establishment of a trade Border in the
Irish sea instead but the unionists felt
that compromised Northern Ireland's
place in the United Kingdom and as a
result of it they have both boycotted
the power sharing Arrangement at
Stormont ever since now it looks like
we're very close to a new Arrangement
but the real test will be outstormant
because even if Rishi sunak manages to
pull this off and he'll be able to claim
that he's avoided a trade war with the
EU and that's quite an accomplishment
and be able to say that it was him and
not Boris Johnson who actually got
brexit done if it's not enough to bring
the unionists back into the power
sharing government at Stormont well the
power sharing administration at the
heart of the Good Friday agreement will
effectively be dared
okay for now David thank you well the
Scottish national party says it will
announce its new leader on the 27th of
March following the resignation of the
first Minister Nicola sturgeon no
individual has officially announced a
bid to become Nicholas sturgeon's
successor several candidates have ruled
themselves out of the race including the
smps Westminster leader Stephen Flynn
the deputy first Minister John Swinney
and the SMP MP Joanna Cherry according
to reports Scottish Health secretary
Hanzo Yusuf is considering entering the
race Mr Youssef is the first non-white
and first Muslim cabinet minister in the
Scottish government
the Royal College of Nursing has
announced its biggest walkout of the pay
dispute in England the union has said no
services will be exempt meaning the
strike will involve for the first time
nursing staff working in emergency
departments intensive care units Cancer
Care and indeed other services our
correspondent Becky Cottrell is with us
at University College Hospital hi Becky
tell us more
well you just pointed out MK those
nurses in critical care departments
walking out that is the first time this
has happened and it is a dramatic
escalation and understandably uh NHS
leaders are raising alarm Bells you know
before we've seen appointments and
procedures canceled because of these NHS
strikes that is nothing to be taken
lightly but now with this new strike you
could see patients showing up for Cancer
Care needing potentially life-saving
procedures and that care is in Jeopardy
interestingly I just spoke to a woman
outside the hospital very emotional her
15 year old daughter is in intensive
care very ill she is terrified about
what this strike could mean but she said
she didn't for a second blame the nurses
she wants the government to do something
about this now the Royal College of
Nursing has said that during this strike
they will be providing life and limb
care and they are talking to the
government about what that will mean
exactly but they said it will be the
absolute minimum level of Staffing and
they are encouraging the NHS to look to
other clinical professions to other
unions to provide cover but even if that
cover is in place there could still be
serious potentially deadly consequences
for patients now this has all come about
of course because talks between the
union and the government overpay and
working conditions have completely
broken down the RCN has accused the
prime minister of refusing to negotiate
and we've seen similar things across the
public sector but of course with NHS
workers with nurses the states are so
much higher
okay but now I thank you and still to
come in just a few moments retracing the
steps that Nicola bully took on that
Friday three weeks ago today from the
edge of the park to this bench um we'll
do that in just a second station
[Music]
foreign
hello again welcome to Seth Michael's on
wire
um we are both High uh we're beside the
river here and we're going to be
retracing the steps of Nicola in just a
few moments time uh before that of
course you know that the police have
been commenting on I'm just going to
take this earpiece out because I'm not
sure what I'm listening to there the
police have been commenting
um on the fact that she had the
menopause she was struggling with the
menopause and she was also struggling
with alcohol issues interesting comments
by the police what is it about the
menopause what is the menopause why did
they highlight that particularly here's
Ashner
like millions of women Nicola bully had
been coping with the adverse effects of
the perimenopause details shared by her
family remind us all of the physical and
mental strain it can have but also of
the lack of awareness for many people it
comes as a surprise and a shock because
it can be very varied but also we have a
situation where for some of our
particularly some of our GPS our
practice nurses Unfortunately they have
never had formal education about
menopause the menopause happens when
women's periods stop usually between the
ages of 45 to 55 but can start earlier
there are over 30 symptoms including
insomnia and night sweats but these
hormone changes can impact mental health
too for one in Four Women the symptoms
are debilitating and for women with
perimenopause they can happen up to a
year before the menstrual cycle stops
Nicola Billy's family say that she had
been struggling with the perimenopause
and had started taking HRT to try and
cope but that in itself started causing
some severe side effects it's a reminder
that whilst this is a widely available
treatment that can be effective at
relieving symptoms for some for others
it can have a very different impact
the women's and equalities committee has
long argued that not enough is being
done to protect menopausal women we know
that the menopause will affect different
people in different ways for some it
will be much more severe than others and
I think the real challenge around the
menopause is that people are given
adequate medical support and assistance
from professionals and not stigmatized
solving those challenges means tackling
that stigma famous faces have been
campaigning for the cause for years
until their voices are heard for half
the population it may continue to feel
like a silent struggle Ashley Sky News
we made our way onto Blackpool Road
we'll tell you why that is important in
just a few moments time as we retrace
the steps of Nicola from three weeks ago
Colin Tennant is with us um hi uh Colin
good to talk to you this morning we've
spoken previously about this case what
are your latest views on it
from a dog point of view
um I still think they should ask the
question to the owners whether the dog
was a swimming dog or an old swimming
dog because
um they say that the dog was dry
which indicates obviously it didn't go
in the river
but it was a swimming dog a dog that
swam and she had fallen into the river
it's more likely that the dog would be
wet and would have jumped into the river
not necessarily because if the dog
thought the lady was drowning but just
the excitement of what was happening
because the dog is used to water
contact Lancashire police but I've had
no reply
it was interesting that the dog was uh
on his own on her own forgive me Willow
um and I wondered if she you know if
she'd moved away if Nicola had moved
away from the river whether the dog
would have followed her but there is a
kissing gate that would have stopped the
dog from doing that do you have any
views on that
well it depends where the dog was found
because with a very short time Gap
if the dog was found Away From the Bench
near the kissing gate when the other dog
walker saw the dog that could indicate
that the dog
um that the lady had left the field and
that's why the dog was at that end
the dog had seen the owner fall into the
water in my view it would have stayed in
that area it wouldn't have wandered up
in that short time frame
what could we glean at all from the
dog's sort of behavior can you tell from
the you know from the body language if
you will of the dog
there's there's two things
um the first is that
again only the owners would know this
has the dog behavior since
its own has been missing how has the dog
been behaving normally or abnormally
fat stress or anxiety could be seen by
the illness and that could be
significant
um but moreover if the owners have or
still do walk the dog in all the local
areas say within a mile
if Nicola was somehow in a location and
she can't move from that location
any dog would scent within 50 or even
200 yards its owner down
eating from that location if you wish
going out in a web type so if you walk
the dog in every direction you know
yourself that when
your dog sees one of your family
um or or more to the point doesn't see
them and then he starts scenting them
out sniffing the air the dog could if
the owner was within half a mile or a
mile of that location it would pick up
the wind Center of its owner very very
quickly by walking in every direction on
every public footpath if the owner was
in that location still
yeah do you think this case will ever be
sold
um
it seems a mystery to Lancashire police
um the idea at the moment that's why
they're putting out
um hypotheticals
I I personally think it will be solved
because all these things are generally
solved although
having said that thousands of people go
missing each year each year and not all
around
is just extremely strange by the
circumstances I think what makes this
one more strange is the fact that the
lady was on the phone
in a work conference
time gap between that and the dog walker
finding a dog was very very narrow
that that's what's unusual
yeah it's good to talk to you thanks so
much India for joining us thank you in
season with me we're going to retrace
the steps as best we can
um in the next minute or so
um but this is a walk that probably took
about 45 minutes something like that
yeah roughly started around 8 40 then
the last kind of known whereabouts of
Nicola was that phone the dog Willow and
the lead all by the bench where we were
earlier on today and that was found at
around 9 30 by a lady who actually lives
nearby so um yeah you know a usual walk
though for Nicola nothing out of the
ordinary that was happening
of course looking for that 10 minute
window which police say that she's been
completely unaccounted for yeah okay and
as far as the police are concerned
they're no clearer now really as to what
happens to her no evidence
a family still questioning what on Earth
has happened yes a main working
hypothesis but police also stressing
they're keeping an open mind the big
question is is three weeks ago when
Nicola bully went missing what happened
in that 10 minute window yeah so what
we're going to do is we're going to
start from the car park which is where
she came with the dog and the kids and
dropped them off at school and then
we're going to walk along the road and
just to give you an overview walk along
the road walk down by the river and then
from there we are going to walk around
the fields and try to get an idea of
what might have happened so that
happened at exactly 8 40. from here what
then what happened so Nicola came parked
up her car here she dropped off her kids
at school she would have taken her dog
Willow out of the car park as she
normally did and walked her along this
path next to the car park of the tennis
club in the school
and along for school to have a look
rather than yeah there we go and this is
a very normal route for Nicola almost
every single morning this is exactly
what she would have done her kids coming
to the school to our left as well
and this is a busy road Inskip down
there is where the family home is so she
would have come down this road and then
on to the road up there a very busy main
road yeah Blackpool Lane it is yeah and
the police have stressed about Blackpool
Lane because there are hundreds of cars
700 Vehicles yeah that would have passed
through that morning and so they are
clear they want to try and speak to
every single one of those drivers to get
as much dash cam footage as they
possibly can to try and piece together
what exactly has gone on so you want to
cross this road
and would have walked down this path
which heads up to not only the bridge
which she crossed but in fact the church
which she would have passed a church
which has been a real focal point over
the last three weeks for a lot of the
the community for Nicholas family
when she's
when when they come here to to kind of
you know just shine a bit of Hope over
what's happened over the last three
weeks okay so 16th century Church a
beautiful building just uh walking past
some of our our colleagues also
broadcasting
um from here the reason it's so poignant
today is that it's three weeks today
since
um she disappeared
yep three weeks today is what she was to
get it's a really lovely church I've
been inside as well it's really lovely
the vicar has spoken to us
a couple of weeks ago spoke of how this
community is really in shock after what
happened three weeks ago and I actually
met Nicholas sister inside this church
just a couple of days ago she was
leaving a message on a tree that's
inside there with the yellow love heart
messages of Hope for Nicola and she
would have come up here
to this Iron Bridge which again has been
another real focal point of the last
three weeks look at all these beautiful
ribbons daffodils that have been tied up
with messages Nicholas partner came down
here leaving a message on one of them as
well and as we just go a bit forward we
get to the other side of the bridge and
essentially the start
of the path which is next to the river
this is the path that runs along the
river wire and it was 8 43 yeah this
time
so you know karate Pace she was walking
out isn't it yeah it was yeah it was
we've you know walked down she's got a
dog with her probably the dog you know
running a bit ahead of you you're
talking about yourself there is a wire
there
yeah that's the river you can see
actually you know there is a bit of a
flow to the river this morning
um but you know this was all normal for
Nicola yeah you know walking along this
path you know the river to a right the
dog would be screwing off ahead of her
dog off the lee by now
yeah that's I mean I'm not entirely sure
whether the dog is still on the lead or
off the lead but certainly when she got
to the fields a bit further up the dog
was definitely uh off the lead
but this is this is her normal walk and
this is of course this this river bank
which has been scoured by police not
only in the Water by divers by
specialist teams but on the banks as
well by forensic police officers they've
really investigated and thoroughly
checked the banks and the water bed gone
down to the Sea and and back again on
several occasions yeah with the scuba
team yeah there has been look you know
there's no denying care there's been a
lot of resource pumped into this
investigation over the last few weeks
yeah there has been you know a really
high-tech equipment used as well to try
and see if they can locate Nicola of
course their working hypothesis is that
she did end up in this River you can
just see as we go around here as well
actually yeah yeah this is the Weir yeah
now what the police say is that it is
very likely that if Nicola was in the
water the force of the river could have
that the flow of the river could have
Center over that Weir and that's where
you see the water picks up the pace
picks up
and she could have gone further
Downstream
okay but you know this has also been a
point where police have been launching
their boats off here to try and get
into some parts of the water to get near
yeah to some of the deep Parts where
they can do some of their diving and see
if they can get any so just to clarify
what's going on here we are trying to
walk at a pace that she would have been
walking up this is exactly what would
have happened three weeks ago she's
walked she's dropped the kids off at
school she's walked along the Blackpool
Lane there and she's moved on to this
path that will take her to her normal
route where she walks the dog Willow
yeah and look at this you know posters
everywhere now yeah Nicholas face is
plastered over this Village yeah we saw
this morning driving in you know even
miles out
missing posters someone with some
evidence who may have been driving that
Friday morning
do you know where Nicola is did you see
anything did you see her entering the
path did you see her leaving the path
was that a possibility yeah but now
we're just walking into a path which
basically takes us to where we've been
broadcasting from this morning yeah and
the next juncture of where people last
saw her yes exactly you know we've seen
already a number of dog walkers this
morning it is a busy dog walking area
plenty of dog walkers almost every
morning I've been told okay that Friday
morning the 27th of January it was very
cold yeah it was really cold and slippy
slippy because of the mud and the ice
yeah and the ice and there weren't as
many dog walkers as they usually would
have been right that morning I mean if
there were more maybe we'd have more
answers by now you know it's a it's a my
new thing that the weather wasn't the
greatest it could have seen more people
out on the footpaths walking their dogs
but you know we're heading to the fields
now where Nicola was cited and there's a
lower fields and an upper field yeah
yeah so there's a
there's a lower field to our left as we
get through this kissing gate and this
gate actually I think we have to mention
because
it will play an important role and then
we talk a bit about
what happened later on
you just get through it yeah so this is
what I mean this is uh basically what we
call a kissing gate isn't it so this
could have been the dog was stuck this
side so she it couldn't come if she went
back this way and that the X that's come
the area that we just walked along that
is where there's no CCTV we go down this
way yes so Nicola would have come
through the gate
and she would have walked onto what is
now the lower field
just a big open space I can imagine
it's not been confirmed but I can
imagine police uh are suggesting that
Nicola would have taken Willow off the
lead here yeah of course and let her
roam about yeah you're a dog walker you
know that's what would and then she'd
have been asking for saying here
um
and we're going to get to the spot now
where she was spotted by another dog
walker yeah that happened in a couple of
minutes time so that was around 8 50. so
we'll get to that shortly so because
what she would have done is and I've
Speak and spoken to dog walkers over the
last three weeks I've been here this is
a normal route for all the locals people
who knew Nicola Nicola herself you can
see actually see the past yeah you know
it's It's A Worn Path people do this on
the regular
and this is where she would have
brought Willow as normal that morning so
what's striking me at the moment is that
she had quite a lick on so you know she
she wasn't sauntering no she wasn't like
um alone with her thoughts she was
properly moving
yeah but I think there is also given
everything that's come out over the last
few days okay
her family and her friends and I think
people in general who are watching this
will be thinking what were Nicholas
thoughts that Friday morning how was she
feeling what was going through her mind
we know she was on her meeting call we
know she texted a friend all that kind
of stuff but what was going through that
Mum of two's mind particularly when just
over two weeks before that morning she
had a visit from police because of
concerns for welfare yeah a medical team
went to the home on the 17th of January
and they haven't told us anything more
than that but we do know that the police
have referred themselves to the
complaints committee
um as a direct result of that um moment
if we just pause here because before we
get
to the upper field it was around this
time roughly
about 850 that Nicola was then spotted
by another dog walker yeah someone who
knew her walking around the lower field
with their dog as well the two dogs
actually interacted before the other dog
walker went off and took the river path
which we've just come down and Nicola
then carried on with her dog Willow and
we wanted to move on we wanted to do
this um retracing of her steps today to
illustrate to people at home you know
what had happened this you know there's
so much intense interest on what has
happened which is the front page picture
on all the papers seemingly every day
and yeah it's difficult to pay place
things together until we sort of do this
sort of walk I suppose especially when
you're in such a rural area look this is
such a quaint Village it's a rural
quaint Village in a rural part of
Lancashire you know it's hard to picture
exactly what went on we've seen Nicholas
face you know but what is is the story
behind Nicola bully what happened to her
in that 10 minute window and that's what
hopefully we can paint an image of what
led up
so that's the upper field yes so now
we're heading into the upper field this
is
so she obviously had an interaction with
the dog walker in the in the lower field
and then she moved uh here to the upper
field it actually just goes up this this
bank here and then we get into the upper
field and that's where and she had her
mind usually walked yeah she had her
mind on work because we know that in a
minute or two she would have messaged
her boss yeah and I think that's a
really important uh he's a bit muddy
here yeah it's a really important thing
to notice actually that you know
um Nicola
be careful Nicola was um you know
thinking about work you know she was
thinking about work and the police have
gathered that from the evidence of her
phone her phone which was left on the
bench still unlocked yeah you know they
will have forensically examined that
um and they will have seen okay she sent
emails she sent texts it was in a couple
of minutes time actually that she would
have
been texting and or emailing and walking
and on the left
you can see the river wire
so her place has slowed a bit because
she's texting and emailing well you'd
think you know you'd think keeping an
eye on Willow you know just having
chatted to a friend thinking about what
she's emailing to her boss yeah is this
the rock wire as well this is yeah this
is all absolutely yeah yeah okay so
that's the where it kind of meanders
round yeah and then heads uh Downstream
but look a vast open field yeah again a
trodden path yeah obviously worn as dog
uses usually would use we've seen some
this morning taking this route yeah as
well and very shortly she would have
just been finishing her email off which
goes to a boss
yeah and um and so she's looking at the
dog she's making sure the dog's all
right you know from my own experience
you keep an eye on them but you're doing
other things as well the Sheep across
the way they're just obviously keeping
an eye on what's going on and then she
sends the email yep at 8 53 police say
right now three weeks ago Nicola hit
send yep and an email was sent to her
boss yeah
and police basically say that you know
that's an important juncture because we
can get a sense that yes she was active
she was on her phone and she was
essentially you know if you're emailing
your boss you're in a fairly decent
frame of mind you know that email didn't
suggest anything otherwise it was a
standard work email yeah and so that's
an important piece
in this route so she would have carried
on here you know with Willow email sent
maybe phone back in the pocket maybe
actually one thing we have noticed K is
Nicola and friends have told us this
Nicola used to take so many photos when
she was out walking right you know her
family shared photos with her with
Willow of of her uh to us you know so
many photos when she'd be out walking
she'd have a Fitbit on
Snapchat was it no that wasn't something
that would have been very useful for the
police but it hadn't been synced up for
a few days yeah and now she's thinking
about doing a teams call well yeah A
team's call would have started at around
uh nine o'clock so in about six minutes
time so so she's thinking about it it's
a work team's call and she's thinking
okay I need to go on that call for nine
o'clock yeah meantime walking by the
river with the dog potentially taking
photographs I don't think she took any
that day did she I'm bitterly cold as
well remember you know Nicola was well
kind of padded up with her clothes think
she had a full length black kind of
padded jacket on she had Wellies on she
had socks her hat a scarf and you know
she was well wrapped up because it was
bitterly cold that morning and muddy
yeah like it is right now and you know
we can see kind of holes and big kind of
divots in the ground but again she was
used to all this
she did it almost every morning she was
used to it there was nothing out of the
ordinary for her whatsoever the last
images we've seen of her are uh getting
in the car aren't they it's a bit windy
forgive me hopefully you can still hear
us
um getting in the car with the kids yeah
and the dog and that was from the
the security at home yes from the front
camera at home and actually you know it
was released it was handed To Us by some
of Nicola's friends you know they were
like look this is what she looked like
on that morning grainy images but we you
know we want to share these so people
can jog their memories and get an
understanding of where she was
what she was doing what she looked like
and you know those were the last images
we've seen of Nicola on that Friday
morning
loading the car as she normally would
and and starting her journey to head to
the school yeah we know that the family
are watching us this morning yeah it's
so difficult for them look I mean I've
been in touch with this family for the
last three weeks
I interviewed them
the the you know her sister Louise her
father Ernie
her mom Dot
it was it was really really tough
because they were just clueless with you
know no answers no evidence
no idea where their sister daughter a
mum a partner has gone to you know I
think the words that they used with me
Kay was that feels like she's vanished
Into Thin Air
that's what they've said and you know
because there's that 10 minute window
which
no one's got any clue what happened to
her and the family you know have had to
be incredibly strong over the last three
weeks because this is a case that we've
seen has taken so many twists and turns
it's had involvement from you know every
Tom Dick and Harry you know on social
media people trying to be involved in
being armchair detectives such a shame
that the family is so impacted by that
you know
um social media it can it can be such a
a poisonous place to be I'm so sorry
that they are impacted so badly yeah I
mean it's you know and they have been
they have been wonderful with us as well
you know giving us information about
Nicola and telling us exactly you know
what kind of a woman she really was but
look here we're heading now
on the path which essentially leads
towards the bench so if we
maybe slow down here a bit maybe we've
been walking slightly so she would she
would have been looking at you know what
was the team's call about it that starts
in a couple of minutes what was it about
so this was a team's call that she would
have then logged on to a work team's
call
the police have actually said that she
wasn't speaking she was just listening
and actually what they said is that
while she was walking she had her phone
out in front of her listening that was
apparently quite normal for Nicola to do
the call would have been on speaker
there would have been other people
talking my camera was off her camera was
off okay and it was just it was just
logged on for her to listen essentially
to what was going on in the call and
that's a really important yeah she was a
mortgage advisor
and her dad had actually told us just a
few days before she went missing you
know he was so chuffed because she just
you know signed off a deal she was
incredibly happy you know she was in
good spirits and I had many anybody seen
her here or there were the two sightings
just the others so just to show you the
other side of the field just there that
she'd walked up and then walked around
in a big loop if you will yeah so just
just up on this side yeah
um someone actually did spot Nicola a
witness uh spotted uh Nicola with her
dog Willow uh they actually then police
spoke to that witness to get more
information they they put out a picture
of the witness that got in touch with
the witness they spoke to them and they
got some information from the witness
just to piece together the timeline of
what we're doing this morning but you
know this is this is a a vast area as we
can see the lower field the upper field
it's a normal move she takes Willow all
the way around and her walk would have
carried on you know I think it always
always one side or the other yeah
exactly and I think look you know you
walk with your dogs she would have taken
it nice and easy
I mean the banks are steep here it has
to be it has to be said and they would
have been slippy but you know you would
have thought most people would be able
to get out of that unless there was some
way where they were injured and couldn't
yeah I mean look there are a whole
different number of questions if the
police's main hypothesis is true K that
nickel ended up in the water the big
question is is why and and how did she
essentially end up in the water they're
the two things that police will really
be trying to answer and that's why
they've scoured this River endlessly to
see if there's any evidence yeah so if
you're just tuning our way we are
retracing the steps of Nicola bully
um three weeks ago today it's nine
o'clock and she would have been on a
team's call about now yeah it was about
a minute about a minute's time or so she
logged into that team's call I imagine
the meeting started at nine o'clock
Nicola logged in about one minute past
nine yeah
she was just walking along this upper
field here yeah she
would have held the phone out in front
of her sorry police said and that's
where that's what you do isn't it yeah
you've got it on speaker yeah you hold
it out in front of you yeah
um and she wasn't talking she wasn't on
video it was just it would have been
slower here because she was listening to
what was being said yeah and again you
know as I mentioned her dad said in
relation to work she was in good spirits
she just as a mortgage advisor had just
got a deal through so she was happy
about that and you know she sent a an
email to her boss that morning around
eight minutes prior to that and you know
she was she was in good spirits it would
see him at the time but the big question
is is that what was going through her
mind you know what was Nicola feeling
that morning we know
she had struggles with alcohol as police
have have revealed we know you know she
was struggling with the menopause
and we know that 17 days prior to her
going missing police had gone to a home
after reports for concern for welfare
how much of a role everything is focused
on this River though isn't it everything
that the kids are kids are at school
they're safe they're happy they're well
the dog's with her we've seen them all
put in the car but the police continue
to focus on this River yeah and it
really has been the focal point of all
of this K you know from day one you know
police had teams here searching around
the Riverbanks searching the area where
she was last seen and then every single
day since there's been so much focus it
will actually turned probably around
towards the end of week two we notice
that police had actually told us they
were focusing their search Downstream so
we're talking you know a good few miles
Downstream comes out near Morecambe yeah
exactly and and actually they were
searching in the scene at one point you
know there were boats out in the sea
searching there and making their way
Upstream to just catch any evidence you
know what would have been what would
have been quite interesting is that they
were actually searching a lot of the
police were actually searching a lot of
the banks because if Nicola had been in
the water it could have been likely she
could have been caught somewhere you
know there could have been a piece of
clothing that could have been caught
onto a branch perhaps on the bank and so
that's been also a very big focal point
for police as they continue their search
so let's recap what we know so far then
she dropped the kids off she walked
across the road there and then onto
Blackpool Lane Blackpool Lane
and it's a busy road I mean the pace
that we were walking out we're working
on timings that we've been given and
people so she was walking really quickly
yeah until she got into the lower field
yes then she starts to slow down and
then she gets here yeah and she must
have stopped because you know I think
the place where she potentially stopped
was actually on the lower field yeah
over here where she met another dog
walker yeah and they they actually had a
chat the dogs had a bit of a play
together you know someone that she knew
as well and so you know I think probably
there was a bit of a break there for a
few minutes yeah as she as she chatted
with that person and police look police
will have spoken to that witness got
details of what the conversation was
like got details of what Nicola was like
that morning as well because that would
be so crucial to their investigation for
all different avenues that police are
investigating but she would have spent a
good few minutes chatting with uh that
witness that police say has come forward
and spoken to them who had a dog a dog
walker who was you know a new Willow and
knew who Nicola was and then she carried
her walk along to the upper field where
we've just actually come round slightly
from she sent the email to her boss
there
then she would have come further and
still on the upper field she would have
dialed into her team's call
so that was one past nine dialing into
her meeting with work and then in a few
minutes time actually approximately
police say because they can't pin exact
timing locations she was then seen by
another witness and that happened
roughly police suggest at around 10 past
nine so we're still a few minutes away
from that so it would suggest that
actually slow down here yeah yeah and
actually probably okay you know you've
got a dog as dog walkers do
just let her dog roam around a bit you
know off the lead run around a bit she's
let the kids drop the kids off at school
she's got a bit of time on her hands it
would suggest and that's why it's taken
you know a bit of time for her to make
her way round lower Field Upper field
and by the river wire here yeah and then
she is seen again in about three or four
minutes yeah roughly about four minutes
time yeah a witness and again someone
who who knows Nicola actually then uh
saw her again and it will have been on
it will have been on this stretch yeah
of a path so adjacent to the the upper
field is what police are suggesting this
route all the way around that we've
taken it's not a big road as a dog
walker it's not a big route you know
this this Loop is going to take you 20
minutes it's not a huge loot
maybe the dog had a chance to run around
in the field you know there's a bigger
what do police want to know that the
potentially people who haven't yet come
forward who would have seen her during
this period of time and that's really
been the appeal we've had you know I
think we've had three police press
conferences now maybe four actually and
every single time they've appealed for
more information people who were driving
on Blackpool Lane that morning to come
forward with dash cam footage in this
time window that we're going through
right now any other dog walkers that
morning who knew what the Nicola looked
like who saw her dog Willow to come
forward and just give us some detail of
what happened in the 10-minute window
which has currently been unaccounted for
this is a busy dog walking area you know
there will have been uh you know a
number of dog walkers although you know
suggested to me that it was bitterly
cold that Friday morning you know there
weren't perhaps as many dog workers as
you would normally suggest it was
incredibly muddy as well you know but
again you've been on the call I'm just
trying to think what she would have been
doing you know but she'd been on the
call she'd been looking at the river the
snowdrops had just out across the way
there she would have been taking in this
Beauty Spot she's not from Lancashire
originally she's from Essex isn't she
and she's moved up to be with her
partner Paul Paul is absolutely sure
that she's not in that River yeah Paul
has said previously you know he is 100
sure that she's not in that River he
actually said that he would like police
to search you know every home speak to
every person in the area Caravan park
over there as well he wants this whole
place thoroughly combed police say look
we we've done that you know we have
investigated all the lines of inquiry in
this area where people they've searched
300 properties yeah so there's 300
properties they've looked they've
searched one across the road three Thai
across the river rather three times you
can actually see I don't know if the
camera can see it but the abandoned
property
um is just to our left okay and that is
a property which has been surged and
police said look she's not she's not in
there and anyone who's come along and
you know people have actually tried to
break into that property uh you know
armchair detectives coming and filming
on Tick Tock and things like that police
have won stay away from that she's not
in there someone still owns that
property
just before we move on because in the
next point when she was spotted
um I was speaking to the council leader
in the seven o'clock hour I'm not sure
if you were with us or not
um and he was saying along here was like
the front at Windermere I mean the
number of people that have been here and
in order to try and be um sleuths or
whatever have their picture taken on the
bench whatever it was
yeah and it is quite sad because look at
the heart of this story K you know
there's a missing woman
and two girls at home without a mum and
they were yeah two little girls yeah and
people were rocking up here you know in
their dozens and it was like it was like
Blackpool seafront you know it was like
a circus at some stage people filming
and you know trying to spot Nicola and
trying to spot evidence you know I think
there was one stage where someone called
out there was something green in the
water it was a chair that they went you
know that police ended up pulling out
but you know people were coming down
here in their absolute numbers to try
and get a sense of what had gone on but
I think also it shows the real interest
that people have had watching this from
wherever they are so she walked into the
field she's seen
um a fellow dog walker who she knows the
dogs have had a little play uh they've
said the farewells
um and then moved on moved into the
upper field and she sends an email to
her boss
um and that is fired off and she
continues to walk along the top of this
field here and she starts to join a
team's conversation the camera's not on
the audio is not on but she is holding
it out in front of us and we know that
because somebody saw her right now yeah
it was at 10 past nine here on the upper
field that somebody then saw Nicola a
witness that has been spoken to by
police so three weeks ago let's put this
in perspective three weeks ago ten past
nine in the morning yeah somebody saw
Nicola walking with her dog Willow here
that was then interrogated by police
police put a picture of that witness out
and that witness came forward spoke to
the police gave us much information as
they possibly could and you know that
was an important juncture in this
because that was the last sighting yeah
Nicola then carried on with her walk
still on the call still on the call
phone out in front of her call on the
speaker listening to what was being said
in this meeting
the thing is now is you know we're not
actually that far okay from the upper
field to the bench further on
and it took 10 minutes 10 minutes from
here to I'm going to say 150 meters 10
minutes yeah you know so what's
happening well what has happened in that
10 minutes and that that is that really
is the big big question what police had
actually said you know her phone moved
towards the bench area that's what they
said they can track that can they yeah
so for the forensics that they've had on
the phone
they just said the phone moved towards
the bench area now look you know I think
that's quite unusual language because
that doesn't say you know nickel has
taken the phone to the bench that
doesn't say you know that um it was it
was directly placed in her hands into
the bench area it just said that the
phone was was moved towards the bench
area and that was between 10 past nine
someone seeing her on the upper field to
20 past nine uh that's where the phone
was moved to and actually subsequently
left all while still logged on this
teams call it a meeting so she's not
walking all this time obviously because
it's not a very far distance for her to
move no and you know maybe the dog is
running around remember the dog off the
lead running around she's
perhaps Willow has gone off somewhere
she's calling Willow maybe
um but you know she's she's not moving
quickly we can you know we can safely
say that because the upper field to the
bench ain't really that far doggy coming
um and you know just to illustrate you
know that this is where um the dog
walkers come
um all the time
um her partner came along Paul
and he's retraced these steps many times
hasn't he yeah he has he has and he came
down pretty much straight away you know
he wanted to see
what was the scene like what happened
here straight away good morning good
morning sir come on how are you no no
not at all good to see you you're Olivia
it has been like that so you you
actually you saw the phone is that right
yeah yeah yeah you saw the phone that
Friday morning yes yeah and that was
around was it after half nine I I gave a
full statement to the police with the
exact ties because excuse me because my
wife's telephone call had uh a lot of
the time on it so yeah but I've given a
full set yeah yeah just on the bench
sure was it just on the bed yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah how's the last three
weeks been
each day something new comes out doesn't
it yeah you know yeah yeah yeah
and and in in terms of you know
when you saw phone lead and Willow who
you you knew who Nicola was I didn't you
knew the willow that was it wasn't you
knew you knew what the you knew I'd seen
I'd see
um but both
the orders of Willow yeah walking this
dog in the passport yeah whilst I knew
them back there it's like I know your
face and another name yeah yeah but you
I remember you actually telling me when
you saw the phone that the lead and
Willow you were like okay I'm gonna keep
an eye on it because something doesn't
feel right I I thought somebody had gone
to the toilet in the uh you know that
would have been that was my first I got
about this red brick building here and I
uh well this this is not right and uh
but then there was a conversation but my
wife was trying to ring me I was trying
to ring her Penny had rung my wife yeah
um to say that she should fasten the dog
up that was that was and Penny was the
lady who actually spotted Willow
initially and saw the phone but didn't
know what was going on with the first
right yeah yeah yeah and and then after
that you know
a progression of of of things happening
you know we found out a couple of the
wallpaper on the phone we found out who
the couple were then the school was
contacted and Paul arrived yeah well
look we'll let you carry on with your
walk I know you do this every morning
Nicola did this almost every morning as
well yeah we're retracing those steps
this time three weeks ago yeah so an
important no I know juncture thank you
very much take care yeah all the best
I mean how important is that you know
someone who always wanted to talk about
the same time every day doesn't he yeah
and one of the first people who actually
spotted
you know the phone on the bench who was
contacted by
the lady who saw it first he came down
here he saw the wallpaper he saw a
picture yeah of who was on there
and then they knew and they contacted
the school because they must have
figured that the kids were at that
school yeah and that would have been the
first Contact and then police would have
been informed and then the search
operation and because it was high risk
they reacted quickly
yeah that that was actually something
that they that they said initially when
they spoke to her partner Paul they
found out that he was high that that
Nicola was high risk and that she had
specific vulnerabilities they then
categorized her as high risk and then
they're like okay and that's because of
what had happened previously the police
had been called hadn't they yeah it was
17 days before
actually the 27th of January so the 10th
of January police had gone round to
Nicola and Paul's home because they had
reports of concerns for welfare and so
look straight away
when that is taken to an account police
said to me that that Rings alarm Bells
you know that really does ring alarm
bells and straight away Nicola has
categorized as high risk just tell us
what happened when the police were
called
well the details are are limited K but
what police have said it was 10th of
January they received those calls they
went round with health professionals
they say medical professionals I'm not
entirely sure what kind of triage team
that is
but they go to the house no one was
arrested at the time
on these you know concerns for welfare
but what they have said is that they are
continuing to investigate what happened
on that day 17 days before Nicola went
missing
um
I'm just looking around as you're
chatting to me and I just look I you
know it there's nothing about this space
that makes you think that
um someone would have disappeared here
and I think that's the real shock to
this community and to you know people
like we're on the dog walker that we
just spoke to a real shock how on Earth
has you know the nation's eyes descended
on this small quaint Village in
Lancashire after a missing mum of two
you know how has that happened how is
that even possible and it's still you
know three weeks on no clues no evidence
there was a whopping question mark over
what on Earth happened three weeks ago
this morning excuse me so she's walking
it's slippy it would have been slippy
when she was here she's using Wellies as
well yeah which would have been tricky
to walk in
um
she's done the loop she's done the lower
field she's done the upper field she's
spoken to the boss she sent oh she sent
an email to her boss she's still got her
phone in front of her still on the
team's Court well this is it's in this
time now between 9 20 and 9 10 of the
the witness spotting Nicola and moving
to the bench it's this 10 minute window
where police the words from police are
her phone moved towards the bench area
so how how did it travel to the bench
area that's a big question we still
don't exactly know that this way
and then this is the river bank we
wander down this way so this is the bank
a lot of people have been asking about
the bank and how steep it is doesn't
look that steep does it no it doesn't in
some areas but if all the way to the
bank no it doesn't but then if you look
Further Down K there is a bit of a drop
are you comfortable going down there
there is a bit of a drop down there and
look it's muddy so please be very
careful it's muddy and slippy and it
would have been probably even muddier at
the time a lot of people have trampled
on here
in the three weeks since nickel has been
missing a lot of people have gone down
to peep over the bank and see if they
can spot anything police have been down
here as well yeah police have also you
know with divers and and um and and
drones and underwater cameras have all
been down here
but clearly a bit of a drop off from the
bank down there so if we move back up
yeah and so this is this is the part of
the river where the police think that
she has gone into the water there's no
sign here at all of um you know any
scuffs or whatever yeah but this is
where her phone is found yeah well look
it's 9 20. yeah right now yeah
9 20 three weeks ago
Nicholas phone had moved to this bench
and this is what police say it was here
that her phone had ended up I'm not
entirely sure exactly where it was
placed but her phone was on a bench yeah
here
and that's where that's where the team
calls it was still ongoing by the way it
was on speaker
she hadn't spoken in it she hadn't got
her camera on but the phone was on the
bench here
and then the dog walker that we just saw
did you say his name was Ron yes Ron but
I mean that that come that comes later
on actually because Ron was you know he
was one of the first people
to notice what had uh what had gone over
here in terms of the phone the lead and
the dog there was actually a another
lady who owns a caravan Park here she
was the first person to notice Willow
scurrying between the bench and uh and
the kissing gate just there but it was 9
20. so around this time the phone the
phone's still on speaker the teams call
still going A team's call with her her
work she was a mortgage advisor she just
you know got got a deal a mortgage deal
just a few days ago her parents told her
she was you know in good spirits about
work she sent an email to her boss
earlier that morning and you know this
is where she ended up well this is where
the phone ended up is what police this
has never been cordoned off
no and you know look that that's a
really big talking point and has been a
huge yeah there's lots of questions
around that straight away police said
that she was high risk that she was a
missing person so there are big
questions as to whether why
there weren't there weren't there wasn't
a cordon around here you know there was
there was huge questions because it it
enabled people and we've seen dozens and
dozens and dozens of people to come here
sit on the bench walk down to the bank
you know and and triple uh trample over
essentially evidence let's just talk
about this because this is the this is a
spot isn't it
um the police think she's gone into the
water there they have uh looked searched
this River
um beneath they've had divers they've
had all sorts of people here to try to
find out what's going on they think that
she is in the water
her partner and the family think that
that is not what she would have done she
just would not have gone into the water
her phone's here the dog is running
around
um
but I know there's a gentleman standing
there but I just wanted to illustrate
the kissing gate being just there there
he goes just moved it off
um kissing Gates there that stretch
there that we walked down about 40
minutes ago doesn't have any CCTV no it
doesn't so what happened in this 10
minutes this is the big question this is
the vital 10 minutes that we're in right
now that police are trying to understand
what happened from 9 20 when Nicholas
phone ended up at this bench still
logged into that team's call to 9 30
when that team's call ended but Nicholas
stayed logged in that that that is a
real crucial 10 minute window that
police are trying to establish what
could have happened right what what are
the options Nicola as police believe
could have ended up in the river wire
how she got there is the big question
why she went in there is the other big
question Nicola the other hypothesis
working hypothesis that police are
keeping an open mind to they tell us
that but believe did not happen there
could have been some third-party
involvement some criminality I don't
think of crimes they don't think so but
it's a hypothesis that they have they
have to
you know keep investor and keep
investigating the third option is as you
mentioned Nicola could have gone through
the kissing gate down the path
the river path and out next to Blackpool
Lane if she turned right
CCTV camera would have spotted her so
police are clear she did not go out that
path onto that busy road and turn right
if she turned left however there is back
to the car yes towards the church and
towards the school there is no CCTV yet
that they've established or dash cam
footage that has spotted her so that is
also a bit of a blind spot at the minute
for police so there are two kind of
hypotheses that they are working on one
is the main one that she ended up in the
river the other one is that potential
blind spot of if she turned left when
coming out of the river path but another
thing police have always said throughout
all this they believe that Nicola did
not leave this area that she did not
leave the fields that is why
they are working on that main hypothesis
that she ended up into what is a cold a
very deep and in some parts a very
fast-flowing River
um
I I just can't get over the setting
really and the fact that a crime could
have potentially have been committed
here and I can't I can't comprehend that
a dog owner would leave the dog here and
walk up that path yeah I mean we've
heard we've heard a lot of different you
know arguments and ideas and people even
telling us this morning in the program
but if Nikola had gone in the water the
dog probably would have followed this
the dog this is a dog that swims we've
actually seen images of Willow the Dog
um wet and in water before so we know
that the dog wouldn't have been afraid
to go in so we're just seeing Ron go now
and we saw where we picked him up so it
gives you an idea that it's actually
it's quite a short Loop here isn't it
yeah it's quite it is quite a short loop
I mean I think Ron's joined us straight
down the path and come yeah come back up
I mean but Nicholas you know walk around
wasn't that you know that that long it
wasn't it wasn't a huge distance
but again it comes back to the question
what was her frame of mind that morning
Kay what was she feeling what was she
thinking I'm sure all that kind of stuff
you know kind of affects the way you
walk the way that that you are in a
morning you know was she walking quickly
clearly not because it's taken a long
time she was taking her time sending
emails on a team's call that team's
called still ongoing right now this time
three until 9 30. UM the police have
debunked some of the
um ridiculous rumors about the fishermen
covering their faces and there was a van
that they wanted to talk about but they
do want more CCTV 700 Vehicles so far
yeah it's dash cam footage which is
vital you're right you know look there's
been so many different theories and
police coming out on the 14th of Feb
with the assistant chief Constable with
the senior investigating officer for the
first time in this case we saw her and
they were adamant they that wanted this
to dispel
a lot of those theories from people
namely you know who hadn't come down to
the scene
and that was a a clear aim for them on
the 14. they came out in force and they
wanted to dispel those theories I think
they did that I think that's fair to say
and it drew people back to right what is
their main working hypothesis now but
obviously in that press conference as
well we heard you know the kind of shock
bombshell really that Nicola you know
had specific vulnerabilities and that
she you know was high risk that morning
and the Home Secretary wants Lancashire
police to explain why they've talked
about alcoholism or misuse of alcohol
shall we say and also the menopause
what's that got to do with it
um so from when we arrived here and we
were telling you about the phone on the
bench which was about ten past nine it
was about about 20 past nine so there's
like there's 10 minutes now so the 10
minutes we've been standing here
something has happened yeah and that's
the big question that's the 10 minutes
why she's disappeared you know that is
what police are trying to identify her
phone was on the bench did Nikki sit on
the bench did she take some time out sat
on the bench was her dog Willow roaming
around you know was he near the water's
edge you know did he go towards the bank
was he having a look over in the water
Nikki's phone was placed on the bench
she was still listening to that team's
call but what happened in that 10
minutes but we don't know if she was
there
that is the big question the phone was
there yeah police are adamant the phone
was there but where was Nikki where was
Nicola bully in that 10 minutes three
weeks ago today and that's a question
that police are really just
trying to answer but it's you know it's
not as if this place is scattered with
CCTV we're in you know a big Field small
area such a small area so Ronnie we just
chatted to he saw the dog uh running
around he saw the phone on the bench and
there was literally no sign whatsoever
of Nicola he saw the screenshot on the
front the wallpaper on the front of the
phone recognized them went to the school
alerted the school who got Paul her
partner who came down very quickly and
and then the search began yeah and three
weeks later and essentially you know
that that search kicked into action
straight away by Lancashire police
excuse me and you know they they really
brought in a lot of Specialists to try
and search for Nicola bully it was my
understanding that actually that search
reduced over the last few days or so but
we're at a very important juncture right
now okay it's 9 30.
uh
Team call that ended and she'd logged on
about 901 it had obviously started at
nine o'clock yeah
um but she stayed logged on so police
say that the team's call ended 9 30.
but Nicola's phone remained logged on to
that team's call in other words she
hadn't ended the call it was still on
there the phone was on the bench where
was Nicola
the phone was still unlocked
the phone was discovered then in two
minutes time or so but
again it was what had happened in that
10 minute window the phone was here but
the call was logged on
no one had cut it off yeah
yeah and the dog was here as well and as
we said the the dog walker Ron who we
spoke to was one of the first here he
was he knew who the phone belonged to
yeah so what actually happened then in
the minutes after that team call ended
a nearby uh resident lives in the house
just around the corner here she was
walking her dogs and had noticed Willow
was scurrying between the bench here and
the kissing gate that's what
this dog walker had noticed what she
then did she actually got a bit of
string she told me and tied Willow up
to the leg of the bench yeah just to
stop her running around she saw that the
lead was on the the harness it was was
on the floor she noticed her phone was
on the bench
she then contacted
some of her friends to try and
understand what to do next
and then Ron who we spoke to earlier was
the second person to come along and see
absolutely everything that was left here
the phone
the lead
and Willow tied up to the bench and then
that's when things really started to get
into action because
yes they noticed that the phone was
still unlocked
Ron spoke to his wife someone had gone
to the Loo didn't he yeah he actually
said oh he thought someone had nipped
off over there gone to the Loo left the
left the dog you know tied up and yeah
but actually when they saw on the lock
screen of Nikki's phone there was an
image
yes there was an image of Nikki and her
partner Paul that resonated and then
things kicked into action where they
thought okay we better call the school
because we know that Nikki's got kids
there and the school then picked it up
from there contacted the police and the
investigation started so that happened
um
three weeks ago right now yeah
approximately police say it was 9 33
three weeks ago that the lady who who
owns a caravan Park just around the
corner here
actually spotted Nicholas phone spotted
Willow and spotted the harness she was
another dog walker so you know she she
noticed who Willow was noticed who
Willow belonged to and then that's when
things really kicked into action I know
the locals got involved yeah so that's
like the the 45 minutes from when she
dropped the children off at school we
walked we've walked her walk today
starting in the car park walking along
Blackpool Lane going past the 16th
century Parish Church very beautiful
building walking down
to where we are and then going around
the loop the lower field and then up to
the upper field sending an email to her
boss saying hello to people that she
knew along the way dialing into a team's
call just after it started at nine
o'clock making a way to where we are now
we know well we know that her phone made
its way to here it was left on the bench
the dog was here the harness was here
there was literally no further sign of
Nicola and that has been the case for
the last three weeks it has been
perplexing for Lancashire police it has
been devastating for her family we'll
have continuing coverage here on Sky
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
and again
um everyone welcome back excuse me we're
live this morning in Saint Michael's on
wire for a special program exactly three
weeks since Nicola bully dropped her
children off at school took the dog for
a walk along the river wire and then
simply
banished
we've been retracing Nicola's last known
movements as they happened over the last
45 minutes or so following the route
Nicola took on her walk that morning and
ending up with her phone left on the
bench behind me
Martin is with us this morning morning
uh Martin so that was the walk it was
about 45 minutes this is really the area
where there was 10 minutes where people
at the police I should say just don't
know what happened I thought it was
quite instructive when you and Lindsay
were walking you were walking at normal
walking pace but you were arriving at
spots quite quickly and I think it it
rather indicated how slowly
um Nicola must have been walking that
morning to start with and then slowing
down yeah she had the dog with her of
course and as you know the dog runs
around and you stop and she had an eye
on the dog she then you know just after
nine o'clock logged into that conference
call with her work colleagues so there
were lots of things going on in her mind
and of course we now know from what the
police have been telling us that she had
her own personal issues so it's it's
easy to see that there was an awful lot
going on for Nicola that morning but she
really was once she got to this part of
the lower field clearly was moving very
very slowly and yeah there are there is
still no evidence at all
to explain why she suddenly disappeared
there's a 10 minute window police have
identified between the last sighting of
her just behind us in the upper field
and somebody seeing her phone on the
bench that 10 minute window is that long
enough for her to have left the
Riverside the police say
in theory yes but practically they found
no evidence that she left the Riverside
so they come back to what they've
described as their main working Theory
hypothesis is that she went for some
reason into the river but they haven't
found her
but there's no CCTV up this path here
and
so they don't know if she went up the
path
that's um and that's what her loved ones
think probably happened yeah well you
know again in the absence of any
evidence that she's come to harm they
will cling to the hope that she's still
alive and if she is still alive that's
perhaps the most logical way of her for
her to have left the Riverside and yes
the conundrum is that there is no CCTV
at the entrance to the path the path
where she came into the Riverside and if
she turned left she would not have been
picked up by any technology which is why
of course they continue to ask for
motorists drivers who may have dashboard
camera footage on that morning you know
around 9 30ish three weeks ago to come
forward they've spoken to lots of
motorists they've viewed lots of footage
but you know as in all these
investigations there may still be one
vital clue out there why would she have
gone down there why would she have gone
down well her family says she wasn't in
the habit of walking by the river
um so we don't know maybe the dog went
towards the river I mean in the first
press conference when the police talked
about the possibility of her going into
the river they did talk about perhaps
there was an issue with the dog
um dog wasn't wet
the dog wasn't wet no so suggests
clearly that the dog hadn't gone in to
the water but the dog may have gone down
to the edge of the water the dog may
have seen something of interest in the
water and if she was concerned about the
dog being close to the water perhaps
Nicola had followed Willow down there
and perhaps may have slipped and we've
seen this morning our cameraman slipped
over on that bank
um you know all of us have nearly
slipped over
um perhaps she did and I'll tell you the
crucial thing is if she had for whatever
reason gone into the water that morning
we know she was wearing an ankle-length
she lay a padded she lay a coat
underneath that she had jeans she had
Wellington Boots short Wellington Boots
you can only imagine that if you fell
into the water or for some other reason
went into the water how quickly your
clothes would absorb that water and it
doesn't matter how good a swimmer you
might be if you're panicking it's very
cold you're filling with water I don't
know your breath might be taken away who
knows
um well certainly I spoke to the council
leader this morning and as you said it's
very slippy here it's only two feet deep
when you first get in but it's 25 feet
deep or thereabouts in the middle
according to Anglers and it is tidal as
well this is what the cancer leader told
me this morning
I think you can always
um you can always learn lessons from
incidents like this obviously the bank
is quite steep it's getting the balance
right though between what is potentially
one terrible incident in people's access
to the river and the ability to walk
into fish and and to do all the things
that they want to do on the river but it
is something you're going to look at yes
I mean we we aren't necessarily
responsible for would be responsible for
fencing it off as a Borough Council but
we would wear with Partners to look at
what we can do across the board to make
the river why I'm also for people yes
you've been a crime correspondent a long
time I think it's fair to say how
surprised were you about what the
council said
uh by what not the council the police
what the police have said
um well uh I was surprised and um it's
very difficult to understand exactly why
they said what they said you know some
intensely personal information about
Nicholas
vulnerability to begin with and then a
further explanation about what they were
talking about
health issues uh severe issues with
significant issues with alcohol
brought on by concerns about the
menopause I mean that's intensely
personal stuff now they say that they
said it to counter lots of rumors and I
think at some stage they had the
families backing to make those
Revelations but the argument is what
significance does it really have in
helping the search for Nicola and The
Wider perception of course is that the
police were victim blaming in a sense
to explain the reasoning behind their
focus on the idea that she went into the
water rather than the other two theories
two other significant theories that are
still you know part of the investigation
it was an extraordinary thing for them
to say for whatever reason and we know
that the Home Secretary is concerned
about it you know Lancashire police
secretary and other MPS and I think
there must be some concern amongst her
family certainly The Wider members of
her family have condemned the police for
what they revealed about the price that
we've not heard from the chief Constable
yet
well I think we're going to enter a
period now of quiet I think the family
are probably going to be reluctant to
say anymore at this stage and I think
the wisest thing probably is for the
police you know until there's a
significant development until they need
or until they need to make a bigger
appeal a new appeal I think we're going
to enter a quiet period where
it's probably best that everybody lets
the police get on with their search for
Nicola yeah indeed so we've actually
heard um from the family not in person
but they did send a statement they said
it's now been three weeks since Nikki
went missing we as a family believe that
the public Focus has become distracted
as we're just hearing there from Martin
actually from finding Nikki and more
about speculation and rumor into her and
Paul's private life due to the
perimenopause Nikki suffered with
significant side effects such as brain
fog Restless sleep and was taking HRT to
help but this was giving her intense
headaches which caused Nikki to stop
taking HRT thinking that that may have
helped her but only ended up causing
this crisis
the public Focus has to be on finding up
and not making up wild theories about
her personal life
Ashner has been looking at the impact
that the menibores can have on women
like millions of women Nicola Billy had
been coping with the adverse effects of
the perimenopause details shared by her
family remind us all of the physical and
mental strain it can have but also of
the lack of awareness
for many people it comes as a surprise
and a shock because it can be very
varied but also we have a situation
where for some of our particularly some
of our GPS our practice nurses
Unfortunately they have never had formal
education about menopause the menopause
happens when women's periods stop
usually between the ages of 45 to 55 but
can start earlier there are over 30
symptoms including insomnia and night
sweats but these hormone changes can
impact mental health too for one in Four
Women the symptoms are debilitating and
for women with perimenopause they can
happen up to a year before the menstrual
cycle stops
Nicola Billy's family say that she had
been struggling with the perimenopause
and had started taking HRT to try and
cope but that in itself started causing
some severe side effects it's a reminder
that whilst this is a widely available
treatment that can be effective at
relieving symptoms for some for others
it can have a very different impact
the women's and equalities committee has
long argued that not enough is being
done to protect menopausal women
we know that the menopause will affect
different people in different ways for
some it will be much more severe than
others and I think the real challenge
around the menopause is that people are
given adequate medical support and
assistance from professionals and not
stigmatized
solving those challenges means tackling
that stigma famous faces have been
campaigning for the cause for years
until their voices are heard for half
the population it may continue to feel
like a silent struggle Ashley Sky News
well joining us now is the former
director of Professional Standards for
the Metropolitan Police that's Stephen
Roberts hello to you Mr Roberts thank
you for joining us um intrigued to know
your comments on this story today
I think what we have to remember is that
at the heart of this there is a
desperately anxious family and we need
to be very very careful that nothing
that we do nothing that we say and
nothing that politicians or the media
say uh makes their situation worse the
media can help the senior investigating
officer needs public awareness needs to
find perhaps that one person who has a
little item of evidence that he may or
may not even know that he has perhaps a
dash cam a piece of film so there needs
to be public awareness it needs to be
kept in front of the public
but the sio has a very difficult job
balancing that need to attract media
attention with the needs of the privacy
of the family and the needs uh to not
hinder the investigation with rumor uh
by disclosing anything that might help
the investigation so it's a very
difficult balance to strike and police
officers have become very used to the
idea that they what they do must be
transparent well that isn't always
possible in a major investigation like
this sometimes it's absolutely essential
to keep some details back from the
public the public may be interested and
the police require the public to be
interested but there is not a public
interest in everything being disclosed
do you think it was reasonable though I
mean there's been a lot of Christmas
criticism not least from the Home
Secretary it would appear in the shadow
Home Secretary about the sort of very
personal detail about uh this missing
lady Nicola bully and the impact that
that has had on her family
absolutely as soon as I heard uh the
first question being answered that the
uh statement that uh Ms bully had
specific vulnerabilities it was
blindingly obvious I have to say that
the next question was going to be well
what are those vulnerabilities
what we don't know and what we should
not judge at this stage is why that
disclosure was made it may simply have
been ill-judged and whilst I hate
criticizing my former colleagues it may
simply have been a misjudgment and a bad
misjudgment at that but there may be
some basic reason within the
investigation within the other
information that police already have
that made it helpful to make that
disclosure we simply cannot judge at
this stage and I I just heard your crime
correspondent saying what the police and
what the senior investigating officer
need now is a period of calm where
they're allowed to get on with their job
without interference from politicians
and without amateur detectives second
guessing the investigation
oh yeah um that was Martin brunt who was
making those comments um I'm I'm sure
that many people would also agree with
you as well but of course there might be
a moment where you know the police have
to accept that they may never find her
oh absolutely that's the case and we can
think back over decades to missing
persons cases where the person who
disappeared was never found uh sometimes
that is so sometimes there simply isn't
any evidence any physical evidence uh
any human evidence of what has happened
to an individual sometimes
tragically we and families are left with
that mystery that he's never sold
okay thank you so much for taking the
time to join us very much appreciated
one of the last people that has saw
Nicola
um was a dog walker called Ron and as we
wandered around the field um taking the
route that Nicola took three weeks ago
today he was walking the other way and
insea took the opportunity to have a
quick chat with him
I gave a full statement to the police
with the exact ties because excuse me
because my wife's telephone call had a
of the time on it so yeah but I've given
a full set yeah yeah you're just on the
bench sure was it just on the bed yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah how's the last
three weeks been
each day something new comes out doesn't
it yeah you know yeah yeah
yeah
and and in in terms of you know when you
saw phone lead and Willow who you you
knew who Nicola was no I didn't you knew
the willow that was it wasn't you knew
you knew what the you knew I'd seen I'd
see
um but both
the orders of Willow yeah walking this
dog in the passport yeah whilst I knew
them back there it's like I know your
face I didn't know the name yeah yeah
but you I remember you actually telling
me when you saw the phone that the lead
and Willow you were like okay I'm going
to keep an eye on it because something
doesn't feel right I I thought somebody
had gone to the toilet in the yeah you
know that would have been that was my
first I got about this red brick
building here and I uh well this this is
not right and uh but then there was a
conversation but my wife was trying to
ring me I was trying to ring her Penny
had rung my wife yeah
um to say that she should fasten the dog
up that was that was and Penny was the
lady who actually spotted Willow
initially and saw the phone but didn't
know what was going on with the first
right yeah yeah yeah and and then after
that you know
a progression of of things happening you
know we found out a couple of the
wallpaper on the phone we found out who
the couple were then the school was
contacted and Paul arrived yeah well
look we'll let you carry on with your
walk I know you do this every morning
Nicola did this almost every morning as
well yeah we're retracing those steps
this time three weeks ago yeah so
important no I know juncture
coming towards the end of our coverage
on this special program today Martin
final thoughts from you the
Nicola is somewhere
the police will continue to search
after the controversy over the last
couple of days I think we're going to
enter we should enter a quiet period and
let the police get on with it
yeah it harks back to there are two
little young girls at home and Nicholas
wider family who are desperate for her
to come home and I think I want to
finish on some words that her family
have said nikoli Nikki is a wonderful
daughter sister partner and mother and
is Miss dearly we all need you back in
our lives we love you so much and your
girls want a cuddle we all need you home
you can reach out to us don't be scared
we all love you so very much
some missing person's inquiry that has
caught the imagination of the whole
country it's been on the front pages of
most of the newspapers for the last
three weeks we've retraced her steps for
you today it was a circular walk not
particularly far people had seen her but
there was a 10 minute window when she
was just behind me on the bench where
you can see people are sitting now and
where is she now that's all her family
want to know where is she now two little
girls at home who need their mummy home
[Music]